Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 49. Ausgabe, in der es heute geht um den heimlichen Superstar der Raumfahrt, den Mars, der hier auch schon ein paar Mal ein Thema war auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. In Ausgabe 27 haben wir über das Projekt Mars 500 gesprochen. Der Versuch der Simulation eines bemannten Marsflugs, der in Russland durchgeführt wurde in Zusammenarbeit von ESA und der russischen Raumfahrtagentur. Und natürlich in der letzten Ausgabe ging es um Mars Express, die ESA-Mission zum Mars, wo das eine oder andere schon zur Sprache kam. Aber heute möchte ich gerne konkret über den Planeten selber reden und darüber, was man darüber weiß und was man noch alles darüber wissen möchte. Und dazu begrüße ich als Gesprächspartner den Ernst, Ernst Hauber. Hallo, guten Tag. Wir sind in Berlin, Adlershof. Hier sollte es anders sein. Institut für Planetenforschung ist ja hier immer mein fester Anlaufpunkt, wenn es um die Planeten und sonstige Objekte unseres Sonnensystems geht. Zu welcher Abteilung innerhalb dieses Instituts gehörst du?
Ich bin in der Abteilung für Planetengeologie.
Geologie. Und der Mars spielt da schon immer eine besondere Rolle für dich?
Der Mars spielt schon immer eine besondere Rolle für mich und auch für die gesamte Abteilung. Denn der Mars ist einfach, gerade wenn es um Geologie geht, im Vergleich zu Physik zum Beispiel oder zu anderen Fachgebieten der Geowissenschaften, dafür ist der Mars immer das eigentlich interessanteste Objekt. Warum? Weil der Mars eine Oberfläche hat, auf der sich viele Prozesse abgespielt haben, die wir geologisch auch von der Erde erkennen. Er hat also Vulkanismus, er hat Tektonik und er hat sehr viel Wasser auf seiner Oberfläche gehabt. Und das unterscheidet ihn von anderen Planeten, wie zum Beispiel von Merkur oder von der Venus, die nur Vulkanismus und Tektonik hatten und Einschläge durch Meteoriten natürlich, aber die keinerlei Spuren von Wasser an der Oberfläche zeigen.
Also ist der Erde sehr ähnlich und dazu auch noch nahe und gut erreichbar im Verhältnis zumindest gesehen zu anderen Objekten im Sonnensystem und naja, das merkt man ja auch. Es gibt zahlreiche Missionen und gerade in der letzten Zeit scheint der Mars ja sich zu einer komplett neuen Popularität aufgeschwungen zu haben.
Ja, das begann 1996 nach einer langen Ruhephase in der Marsforschung. Seither sind eigentlich alle paar Jahre mindestens eine Sonde aufgebrochen bei jeder günstigen Gelegenheit, dorthin zu kommen und es dauert bis jetzt an. Im Augenblick sind immer noch drei Orbiter um den Mars aktiv, also drei Sonden, die in einer Umlaufbahn sind. Auf der Oberfläche fahren zurzeit zwei Rover um und die nächsten Missionen sind auch schon geplant. Es ist also nach wie vor viel los am Mars.
Richtig, richtig was los. Bevor wir da vielleicht auf den Mars dann nochmal im Besonderen kommen, würde mich natürlich zu Beginn nochmal kurz so deinen Weg interessieren, hier in diesen Bereich der Planetengeologie. Wann hat es dich erwischt? Bist du auch noch so ein Mondlandungsopfer?
Nein, nein. Es war vor meiner Zeit. Ich bin Geologe, das heißt, ich habe auch tatsächlich Geologie ganz normal studiert in München und hatte mich damals schon für Fernerkundung interessiert, ohne noch an Planeten zu denken. An der LMU in München? Und ich hatte mich immer mit Begeisterung auf Satellitenbilder oder Luftbilder von irrtischen geologischen Formationen gestürzt, habe in meiner Diplomarbeit, damals war es noch Diplom, auch Satellitenbilder von Sardinien ausgewertet bzw. Luftbilder und dadurch bin ich dann in Richtung der Planetenforschung gekommen, weil dort ja Satellitenbilder das einzige Medium sind, mit dem man Geologie vernünftigerweise damals zumindest machen konnte. Es gab vom Mars viele Bilder und sehr wenige sonstige Daten.
Was kann man da von Sardinien lernen?
Von Sardinien kann man eigentlich für den Mars gar nichts lernen, das war einfach noch meine Diplomarbeit, die hatte mit dem Mars überhaupt nichts zu tun. Da ging es um Sedimente und um Minen im Südwesten von Sardinien, das war ganz was anderes.
Aber diese Raumfahrtorientierung hast du schon immer gehabt?
Die kam eben so weit Fernerkundung zur Raumfahrt, Zelti war schon immer im Studium da auch schon, aber die Planeten kamen erst nachher.
Und dann bist du schon direkt zum DLR gewechselt?
Dann bin ich zum DLR gewechselt, war damals noch in Oberpfaffenhofen, das Institut für Optoelektronik und dann sind wir im Laufe der Jahre nach Berlin umgezogen, wo dann hier das Institut für Planetenforschung neu gegründet wurde, mit den verschiedenen Abteilungen, von denen eine die Planetengeologie ist.
Ja, der Mars. So wie auch die Venus, die wir hier vor zwei Folgen auch noch einmal genau auseinandergenommen haben. So einer unserer unmittelbaren Nachbarn und in Größe und ja, sagen wir mal im Bereich der Chancen, ein interessanter Planet zu werden. Der Erde halt sehr ähnlich. Wie wir wissen, ist die Erde da halt im Sonderstatus gefangen, während die anderen sich alle ein bisschen anders entwickelt haben, als das vielleicht für uns und unsere Urlaubsvorstellungen so angemessen gewesen wäre. Aber es ist ja auch jetzt ein Planet, der früh, der gut sichtbar ist am Himmel und von daher auch früh entdeckt wurde und schon früh die Fantasie der Menschheit beflügelt hat. Wenn man jetzt mal so über die Zeit guckt, wie hat sich das Bild des Mars verändert und was hat dazu geführt, dass das Bild sich verändert hat?
Der Mars ist in der Tat schon mit bloßem Auge von den anderen Sternen in Anführungszeichen zu unterscheiden. Er ist nämlich tatsächlich rot. Also wenn sie rauf schauen bei einer günstigen Gelegenheit, dann sieht man, dass der eindeutig rötlicher ist, wie die anderen Sterne und auch die anderen Planeten. Das heißt, er war schon früh in der Antike als spezieller Himmelskörper erkannt worden und die Röte, das ist auch schon oft gesagt worden, hat dann dazu geführt, zumindest in der Interpretation vieler Leute, dass er oft mit Krieg, mit Blut in Verbindung gebracht worden ist. Das war dann lange so ziemlich alles, was über den Mars zu sagen war. Erst mit Erfindung der Teleskope hat sich das dann geändert. Man konnte immer noch nicht allzu viel erkennen. Manche Leute haben Artifakte, künstliche oder visuelle Erscheinungen in den Teleskoptaten als Nachweis menschlicher Aktivität auf den Mars genommen. Menschen im Synonym intelligente Lebewesen. Sie haben dort über Kanäle spekuliert, die angelegt worden wären, um einen wüstenartigen Planeten zu bewässern. Das war schon relativ spät. Das war Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Der Name, der in dem Zusammenhang immer wieder genannt wird, ist Percival Lowell. Er hat im Arizona-Eigensten-Institut ein Observatorium gebaut, um das genauer untersuchen zu können. Als die Teleskope dann besser geworden sind und immer mehr Leute nachgeschaut haben, hat sich dann relativ schnell herausgestellt, dass das, was er als Kanäle zu erkennen geglaubt hat, einfach nichts war. Da gibt es keine Kanäle, da gibt es auch keine Linien. Dann hat das Interesse wieder stark abgenommen, insbesondere als später in den 50er Jahren mit den ersten wirklich guten wissenschaftlichen Spektren, die man aus der Mars-Atmosphäre gewonnen hat, klar war, die ist sehr dünn. Das heißt, es muss auf dem Mars sehr kalt sein. Die Atmosphäre besteht hauptsächlich aus Kohlendioxid.
Also einfach durch Spektroskopie, dessen, was man gesehen hat aus der Ferne, könnte man schon die Atmosphäre so gut einschätzen, dass man sagt, okay.
Ja, das war bereits möglich. Man schaut sich an, woraus besteht sie und wie dünn ist sie. Das ging mit Teleskopen schon ganz gut. Die Werte waren noch nicht endgültig.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Von der zweiten Hälfte der 50er Jahre. Also kurz vor den ersten Raumschiffen losflogen, die dann auch tatsächlich losflogen. Zuerst mal sind sie bloß vorbeigeflogen, sie sind also nicht gleich in die Umlaufbahn eingeschwenkt. Vorbeifliegen ist leichter. Das heißt, man konnte immer nur eine Seite vom Mars aufnehmen mit den ersten Kameras. Und die Bilder haben was gezeigt, einfach nur Krater, so wie auf dem Mond.
Was war da so die erste Mission, die da hingehen konnte?
Die erste Mission war, glaube ich, Mariner 4, ist die.
Diese Mariner-Missionen, die die Planeten ein bisschen näher zu betrachten.
Das war eine ganze Klasse von Raumsonden, die sind zu verschiedenen Himmelskörpern geflogen. Merkur war dann Mariner 10 zum Beispiel, einige Mariner zum Mars. Venus ist, glaube ich, kein Mariner hingeflogen, soweit ich weiß. Oder sie haben es versucht.
Doch, die 10 ist auf dem Weg zu Merkur.
Die ersten Mariner, zumindest Mars 4 und 5 und 6, glaube ich, waren Enttäuschungen. Man hat etwas gesehen, was einen um den Mond erinnert hat. Man hat dann geglaubt, naja, das ist wohl endgültig der Todesstoß für all die, die an Leben auf dem Mars geglaubt haben oder vielleicht sogar intelligentes Leben. Denn wenn es dort so ausschaut wie auf dem Mond, dann ist es auch so wie auf dem Mond und der ist tot. Da war man sich damals schon ziemlich sicher. Und die Apollo-Proben, die Apollo-Missionen haben das ja dann eindrucksvoll bestätigt. Aber die letzte Mariner-Sonde, die zum Mars geflogen ist, Mariner 9, das war 1970, 71, die hat dann eine Revolution verursacht im Bild, das wir vom Mars haben. Sie hat nämlich erstens den Mars als erstes global aufgenommen. Sie war die erste Sonde, die in eine Umlaufbahn eingeschwenkt ist. Das war wichtig, um sozusagen auch die Rückseite in Anführungszeichen zu sehen. Und was sich da gezeigt hat, war das Bild eines Planeten, der extrem viel abwechslungsreicher ist, als man das bis dato angenommen hatte. Man hat Vulkane gesehen. Es war also klar, der Planet muss intern so viel Energie entwickelt haben, dass Material geschmolzen ist und dann in Form von Vulkane.
Also keine aktiven Vulkane natürlich.
Keine aktiven Vulkane, aber immerhin Vulkane. Das war ja auch schon mal was. Man hat tektonische Bruchstrukturen auf der Oberfläche gesehen. Es war also klar, die Oberfläche musste durch Spannungen so beeinflusst worden sein, dass sie zerbrochen ist und sich verformt hat. Also auch da Nachweis innerer Aktivität. Und man hat viel gesehen, was auf sogenannte exogene Prozesse hinweist. Also Prozesse, die durch die Einwirkung von Gasen in der Atmosphäre hinweisen. Man hat gesehen, dass es Strukturen gibt, die wahrscheinlich von Eis verursacht worden sind. Und man hat, und das war das Allerwichtigste, man hat Täler gesehen, die so ausschauen wie auf der Erde. Täler ausschauen, durch die Flüsse fließen. Kleine Flüsse zuerst, kleine Bäche, die dann zu größeren Flüssen und dann zu strömen werden. Vernetzte Talsysteme. Den drittisch nennt man sich oft vom griechischen Wort verbaum, der in seinen Zweigen ja auch immer feiner ausläuft. Und das alles hat dann gezeigt, Mensch, der Mars, der hat doch mehr zu bieten, als wir jetzt dachten. Den müssen wir genauer unter die Blut nehmen. Denn wo Wasser ist, steht auch Chance auf mehr. Und dieses Meer, das wäre natürlich Leben. Und deswegen war die nächste Mission dann nach dieser großen Revolution 1970, 71, die Viking-Mission, die bestand aus zwei Sonden, identischen Sonden, die dort gelandet sind. Zusätzlich gab es auch noch zwei Schwester-Sonden, die in die Umlaufbahn gegangen sind. Zuerst waren die hauptsächlich dafür gedacht, mit den Bildern aus der Umlaufbahn die genaue Landestelle festzulegen, ist dann auch gemacht worden. Es hat sich dann gezeigt, dass die Umlaufsonden recht langlebig waren. Und die haben einen wunderbaren Bilddatensatz geliefert, der über die nächsten 20 Jahre dann intensiv ausgewertet worden ist. Aber das Kernstück der Mission war natürlich die Länder, die extrem ausgefeilte Laboratorien an Bord hatten, mit denen man auf verschiedene Weisen versucht hat, Leben nachzuweisen.
Das war ja eigentlich das erste Mal, dass jetzt nach dem Mond überhaupt auf irgendetwas gelandet ist, was der Mensch mal losgeschickt hat. War doch der erste Mal nach dem Mond?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob die Sowjets schon vor den Viking-Sonden mal kurz auf dem Mars gelandet sind. Das hat aber alles nicht so richtig funktioniert. Also man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass die Viking-Sonden die ersten erfolgreichen Sonden waren, die auf dem Mars gelandet sind. Und dazu noch, das waren nicht irgendwelche Sonden, sondern es waren richtig schöne, große, teure Geräte, mit denen gezielt nach Leben gesucht werden sollte. Das war eindeutig der Hauptzweck der Mission. Der Zweck ist schon erreicht worden, die Suche, aber das erhoffte Ziel wurde nicht erreicht, nämlich organische Bestandteile oder gar Leben wurden nicht nachgewiesen. Was dann wieder zu einem Apeppen der Begeisterung geführt hat, denn wenn er zwar eine interessante Vergangenheit hatte, die aber nie zu leben geführt hat, dann ist es vielleicht doch nicht wert, dass man sich näher damit auseinandersetzt. So schien zumindest die Einschätzung vieler Leute zu sein, denn nach diesen Viking-Sonden war erst mal Funkstille vom Mars. Lange Zeit nichts mehr passiert. Und dann war lange Zeit Schluss. Die Viking-Sonden haben aufgehört, so Ende der 70er Jahre, Anfang der 80er Jahre was zu liefern. Die vier Komponenten, also zwei Umlaufsonden und die Länder, waren nicht alle gleich lang aktiv. Dann war erst mal wirklich Schluss. Die nächste Sonde, die geplant war, war eine amerikanische Sonde. Mars Observer hieß die. Das wäre ein großer Orbiter gewesen. Mit sehr schönen Instrumenten, die aus der Umlaufbahn den Planeten kartieren sollten. Das wäre Anfang der 90er Jahre gewesen. Aber der scheiterte beim Eintritt in die Mars-Umlaufbahn. Man weiß immer noch nicht genau, was passiert ist. Wieder eine große Enttäuschung. Die Russen hatten zu der Zeit ihre eigenen Pläne verfolgt. Aber zu der Zeit war der Übergang der Sowjetunion zur Nachperestroika-Zeit. Und die ambitionierten Sonden, die sie damals in Planung hatten, die Phobos-Sonden, die flogen zu einem Mond des Mars, Phobos. Die sind leider auch beide, mehr oder weniger, gescheitert. Die erste wegen eines Softwarefehlers, schon im Anflug. Die zweite auch. Kaum war sie am Phobos angekommen, beziehungsweise am Mars-Phobos-System. Und dann war bei den Russen da auch erstmal Schluss. Sie hatten noch eine weitere extrem ambitionierte Mission geplant, die mehrfach umbenannt wurde, je nachdem in welchem Stadium des Zerfalls der Sowjetinum, beziehungsweise des Übergangs zum Russland des heutigen Zeitalters, da gerade aktiv war. Die hieß zum Schluss Mars 96, nach dem erhofften Startdatum 1996. Und diese Mission wäre, das ist immer noch die Einschätzung vieler Leute, eine der innovativsten Sonden gewesen, eine der größten, die jemals zu einem anderen Planeten geflogen wäre. Sie hatte viele, sehr viele Instrumente an Bord, unter anderem auch einige aus westeuropäischen Ländern und wäre ein absoluter Meilenstein in der Marsforschung geworden. Leider kam es nicht dazu.
Warum? Also was war da so innovativ dran?
Innovativ war, dass es eine extrem große interdisziplinäre Anzahl an Instrumenten war, die unter anderem Sachen an Bord hatten, wie extrem komplizierte oder komplexe Spektrometer, die erstmals wirklich die Zusammensetzung der Mars-Oberfläche im Hinblick auf Mineralologie z.B. hätten untersuchen sollen. Auch, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr ganz im Bilde, welche Instrumente von noch in sowjetischer Zeit geplanten Sachen da dabei gewesen werden, aber auch da waren viele Sachen dabei, die meines Wissens bis jetzt nicht mehr wiederholt worden sind.
Ah, ich sehe gerade hier Seismometer z.B.
Ja, sie hatte auch eine Landekomponente auf dem Länderwehr. Ja, Seismometer, da wäre auch so eine Art Windmesser. Laser-Komponente dabei gewesen, mit dem man Gestein vaporisiert hätte und dann das Plasma untersucht hätte. Etwas, was jetzt Curiosity wieder versucht, 20 Jahre später. Also das war wirklich schade, dass die Mission gescheitert ist. Sie ist gestartet auf einer Proton-Rakete, hat aber leider die Erdumlaufbahn nicht verlassen können und ist im Endeffekt dann wieder auf die Erde zurückgestürzt.
Ja, die Russen haben da überhaupt sehr wenig Glück. Auch die letzte Mission, diese Phobos-Grundmission, nach langer Zeit.
Leider keine Fortünen, was Mars angeht.
Hat es auch nicht geschafft. Ja, das ist irgendwie wirklich haarig. Also warum es dann auch immer ausgerechnet die Mars-Missionen sind, obwohl es ja gar nicht immer am Mars gescheitert ist.
Man weiß es nicht, aber die letzte Mission, die letzte gescheitert ist, auf Phobos Grund, wird sicher dazu führen, dass viele Leute den richtigen Aberglauben entwickeln, wenn es darum geht, Russen und Mars in Zusammenhang zu bringen.
Ja, lass mal lieber an anderen Planeten leben. Ja, dafür hatten die Amerikaner sehr viel mehr Erfolg. Das klang ja schon an. Also Viking war im Prinzip einer, große Leistung. Und dann Mitte der 90er-Jahre gab es ja dann gleich das nächste Lander. Mars Observer hat nicht funktioniert. Dann war Pathfinder dann das nächste schon.
Pathfinder war der nächste. Das war eine ganz kleine Mission, die sollte eigentlich hauptsächlich die Fähigkeit demonstrieren, auf dem Mars mit einem Rover landen zu können. Die Viking-Sonden waren ja Länder, die sind nicht weiter rumgefahren.
Die standen einfach nur rum.
Genau, und haben gemessen. Jetzt sollte der nächste Schritt gemacht werden. Wir fahren dann auch auf dem Mars rum. Mobilität auf einem geologisch komplexen Körper wie dem Mars ist sehr wünschenswert. Denn wo viel los war, ändert sich auch die Oberflächengeologie von manchmal von einem Kilometer zum nächsten. Und es wäre schade, wenn man irgendwo gelandet ist, sieht in einem Kilometer Entfernung etwas ganz Interessantes, kann aber nicht hinfahren. Das will man natürlich nicht. Man will fahren können. Das unterscheidet den Mars von geologisch einfacheren Körpern wie Asteroiden, kleinen Körpern, wo die Oberfläche in erster Näherung homogen ist. Da gibt es wenig Grund, rumfahren zu müssen. Das heißt, da kann man landen und alles, was es dort gibt, kann man auch vom Länder aus erfassen. Das ändert sich mit zunehmender Größe und Komplexität eines Planeten. Und bei Mars, so viel war ziemlich früh klar, schon eigentlich nach Meriner, der ist so vielfältig an der Oberfläche, dass man idealerweise natürlich rumfahren können will. Man will von einem interessanten Punkt zum nächsten fahren.
Das haben die Amerikaner ja auch schon auf dem Mond geschafft. Da haben die Leute mit dem Fahrzeug durch die Gegend gefahren.
Genau, das haben die Amerikaner auf dem Mond geschafft. Das haben die Sowjets übrigens auch auf dem Mond geschafft. Mit ihrem Lunokhod-Rover, der da 38 Kilometer weit rumgefahren ist. Und man musste oder man wollte auf jeden Fall das auf dem Mars auch erproben. Pathfinder war die Mission, die das demonstrieren sollte. Ein kleiner Rover, war nicht viel größer, etwas despektierlich gesagt, wie ein Schuhkarton. Hatte auch eine relativ begrenzte wissenschaftliche Nutzlast an Bord. Es war natürlich eine Kamera drauf, braucht man, wenn man fahren will. Und das wichtigste Instrument war ein Spektrometer, mit dem man die Elementzusammensetzung des Mars, Bodens bzw. der Steine ausmessen konnte. Der kam aus Deutschland, aus dem Mainzer Institut für Kosmosforschung, oder, wie heißt es gleich wieder, Kosmochämie. Genau. Und der Federführung von Professor Heinrich Wenke damals gebaut. Und das war ein ganz tolles Instrument. Das hat also, dem Instrument ist es zu verdanken, dass die Mission nicht nur gezeigt hat, man kann landen und rumfahren, sondern dass man auch schöne wissenschaftliche Daten zur Zusammensetzung der basaltischen Gesteine nehmen konnte, die dort rumlagen. Fahren konnte er allerdings nicht besonders weit, er ist mehr oder weniger dieser Rover, bloß um die Struktur herum gefahren, die ihn abgesetzt hat. Auf dieser Struktur war die Kamera, er hat in der Gegend herum geschaut und da ist er ein bisschen drum herum gefahren. Also das war nicht besonders weit. Es hat auch nichts gebracht, die Gegend war so eintönig, dass er da schon sehr weit hätte fahren müssen, um überhaupt an wirklich was signifikant anderes zu kommen.
Aber man hat zumindest gezeigt, es geht.
Man hat gezeigt, es geht. Gleichzeitig zu dieser Zeit wurde auch eine extrem aufsehende, erregende Studie im Magazin Science veröffentlicht. Da hatten sich Leute Meteorite angeschaut, geht es auch nur gesagt einen Meteoriten angeschaut, der aus der kleinen Gruppe von Meteoriten stand, die vom Mars kommen. Man weiß, dass die vom Mars kommen, weil winzige Gaseinschlüsse in diesen Meteoriten genau die gleiche Zusammensetzung aufweisen, wie die Mars-Atmosphäre. Das ist ein extrem starker Hinweis, dass sie auch wirklich vom Mars kommen, denn es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Himmelskörper, wo solche Meteoriten herkommen können und die dies gibt, die haben keine Atmosphäre mit der Zusammensetzung.
Das sind Bruchstücke, die vielleicht durch einen Einschlag auf dem Mars mal herausgeschossen wurden und es dann auf eine same Weise direkt bis zur Erde geschafft haben.
Die hatten genug Energie durch den Auswurf bei einem Krater mitbekommen, um das schwere Feld vom Mars zu verlassen. Und sind dann über eine gewisse Zeit in der Umlaufbahn um die Sonne gelaufen und immer näher zur Erde gekommen und dann irgendwann hier eingeschlagen. Davon gibt es inzwischen ja und gefunden. Man gibt eigene Programme dafür, die auf die Suche nach solchen Meteoriten gehen. Die findet man nicht überall so leicht. Wo suchen die?
Auf der Erde oder noch im Anflug?
Die suchen auf der Erde. Und da gibt es zwei Gebiete, in denen man solche Meteoriten sehr einfach erkennen kann. Das eine ist die Antarktis, denn wenn da ein Stein auf dem Eis rumliegt, sieht man ihn schon aus der Ferne. Und das zweite ist eine Wüste. Da sehen sie auch relativ schnell, ob da ein Stein rumliegt, das ganz anders ist als der Rest. In einer Gegend wie Deutschland könnte man lang suchen. Da gibt es die natürlich auch, aber da wächst alles zu. Da ist es nahezu unmöglich, gezielt nach sowas zu suchen. Gut, inzwischen gibt es ein paar Dutzend von solchen Meteoriten. Damals, Mitte der 90er Jahre, waren es noch weniger. Und in einem dieser Meteoriten hatte eine Forschergruppe Strukturen entdeckt, die morphologisch ein bisschen so aussahen wie Bakterien, Mikroorganismen. Und da sie zusätzlich noch ein paar Minerale entdeckt haben, die auf der Erde auch durch die Einwirkung von Organismen entstehen, war es sozusagen so eine Art Kombination aus Hinweisen, die die Forscher dazu verleitet hat, darüber zu spekulieren, ob das nicht der Nachweis von Leben auf dem Mars ist. Hat natürlich eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe. Ist klar, das war damals nach langer Ruhezeit der erste richtig aufsehenerregende Artikel, der über den Mars geschrieben worden ist. Und dann haben sich viele andere Leute auch auf diesen Meteoriten gestürzt, haben winzige Bruchstücke davon untersucht und haben diese Theorie, dass da Leben oder die Spuren von Leben zu sehen wären in diesen Meteoriten ziemlich schnell pulverisiert. Und soweit ich weiß, glaubt im Augenblick, außer der ursprünglichen Gruppe, die das veröffentlicht hat, eigentlich niemand mehr, dass das wirklich Spuren nach Leben sind. Aber seitdem wir Molle, das hat zu einem enormen Anstieg des Interesses für den Mars geführt oder am Mars geführt und nach diesem 96er sozusagen Initialzündfunken dann wieder, Pathfinder und diese Meteorstudie Leben auf dem Mars, hat die USA, also die NASA beschlossen, wir brauchen jetzt ein richtiges Mars-Programm. Und das hat dann im Endeffekt dazu geführt, dass sie gesagt haben, wir müssen eigentlich alle zwei Jahre.
Was hat denn Pathfinder jetzt noch herausgefunden? Man sagt es ja, durch das Instrument von den Mainzern hätte man da die Umgebung ganz gut analysieren können. Was wurde denn dabei gefunden, was einen jetzt so in Begeisterung versetzt hat?
Also meines Erachtens wurde nichts gefunden, was die Geologen wirklich in Begeisterung gefunden haben. Das sieht das Instrument-Team vielleicht ein bisschen anders. Was sie gefunden haben, ist ein Hinweis darauf, dass die Mars-Oberfläche daraus besteht, was man eh schon immer geglaubt hat, nämlich Basalt. Und dann gab es noch ein paar interessanter Details jetzt, dass zum Beispiel viel Schwefel in dem Boden gefunden worden ist. Das hat Viking-Ergebnisse bestätigt. Aber nichts davon war jetzt irgendwie etwas, was gesagt hat, jetzt müssen wir unser Bild vom Mars umstellen.
Okay, aber auch so die Bestätigung. Man hat gezeigt, dass man es auch bestätigen kann.
Ja, aber das Entscheidende war, dass da wirklich ein Ding auf dem Mars rumgefahren ist. Das konnte man auch von dieser Landeinheit aus fotografieren. Man hat also richtig gesehen, wie es auf dem Mars rumguckte. Und das war einfach spannend, das war super, das hat gezeigt, wir können es ja doch noch auf dem Mars was wirklich Tolles machen. Aber gerade weil die Wissenschaft sozusagen limitiert war, war schnell klar, damit ist es nicht getan. Man braucht mehr, man will mehr. Und deswegen ist eine ganze Reihe anderer Missionen beschlossen worden, die zum Teil geklappt haben, zum Teil aber auch nicht geklappt. Also nicht nur die Sowjets oder später die Russen haben Pech mit Mars, auch die Amerikaner haben viele Fehlschläge gehabt. Mars Observer war einer davon, aber später dann gab es gleich zwei kurz hintereinander. Das war der Mars Polar Länder und ein Mars Surveyor. Das eine wäre ein Orbiter gewesen, das andere wieder gesagt ein Länder, der in der Nähe von Pol landen hätte. Die sollen beide gescheitert. Hat aber die NASA nicht dazu verleitet, das Mars-Programm gleich wieder einzustampfen. Kaum, dass es begonnen hatte. Sie haben weitergemacht und hatten auch dann recht schnell sehr große Erfolge. Ein ganz wichtiger aus meiner Sicht ist der Mars Global Surveyor, der als eines meiner Lieblingsinstrumente von allen einen Laser-Altimeter an Bord hatte, mit dem man erstmals die Topographie der Mars-Oberfläche in extrem guter Genauigkeit global erfassen konnte. Das war ein Datensatz, der hat vielen Leuten sehr viel weiter geholfen. Und so ging es dann weiter mit immer mehr Messungen.
Der war ja auch noch 1996, der Start dann?
Der war relativ schnell angekommen. Sind Sie glaube ich 1998 schon? Mars Global Survey, 1997 oder 1998 war er dort. Das war ein Orbiter.
März 1999.
Komisch, ich dachte irgendwie, ich hätte im Kopf, dass die ersten Ergebnisse schon 1998 publiziert worden sind.
Aber wenn es da in dem Internet fliegt, muss das stimmen. Also die Zielumlaufbahn war letzten Endes dann erreicht.
Vielleicht kurz vorher schon.
Der eigentliche Flug war sogar schon September 1997 durch.
Diese Mission hatte eine langanhaltende Phase, mit der man vom Anflug in den Zielorbit überging. Die Phase hieß Aero-Breaking. Man hat immer die Atmosphäre ein bisschen berührt, mit der Sonde, dadurch abgebrengst. Breaking, Bremsen auf Englisch. Man hat also die Luft zum Bremsen genützt. Und das hat ziemlich lange gedauert, um dann zuerst in eine extrem eliptische Umlaufbahn einzuschwenken. Da kamen dann die ersten Ergebnisse, das waren diese Publikationen, auf die ich angespielt habe. Und dann ist man immer weiter runtergegangen, bis man in einem kreisförmigen, endgültigen sogenannten Kartierorbit war. Und dann ging es richtig los.
Ah ja, okay, also ein anderthalb Jahr hat man gebraucht, um sich da einzupflügen.
Ist langwierig, ist mühsam, ist auch riskant, aber man spart Treibstoff, wenn man nicht die Raketen zum Bremsen benutzt, sondern den Mars selber des Bremsen erledigen lässt. Über Reibung in der Atmosphäre. Und diese Sonde hat dann sehr lange durchgehalten. Ich glaube, es ist nach wie vor die am längsten operierende Sonde auf Mars. Sie ist mittlerweile nicht mehr aktiv, aber sie hat glaube ich knapp 10 Jahre lang oder sogar über 10 Jahre lang Daten geliefert. Ein Riesenerfolg für die NASA.
Genau, 2. November 2006. Aufgrund eines Fehlers des Bodenpersonals heißt es hier. Ja, sehr dramatisch.
Es ist bitter.
Ja, das heißt, man hatte auch schon in zunehmendem Maße genauere, feinere Daten. Also die Oberfläche wurde immer genauer vermessen. Was hat man denn, ich weiß nicht, oder wollen wir jetzt erst mal gleich mit den anderen Ländern weitermachen? Mich hat ja so voll interessiert, wie so der Informationszuwachs war. Also hat man da jetzt irgendwas, war das jetzt immer nur alles ein bisschen genauer, das, was man schon dachte, was es ist? Oder hat sich in dem Zuge schon irgendetwas Neues ergeben, was man gar nicht wusste?
Hatte es. MOC, also dieser Mars Global Surveyer, hatte eine Kamera an Bord, die ist MOC, Mars Orbiter Camera. Und diese Kamera hatte die Fähigkeit, den Mars mit einer Auflösung von wenigen Metern pro Bildpunkt darzustellen. Das heißt, man hätte ein Gebäude als solches erkennen können. Ein Gebäude ist ja 10, 20 Meter lang in jeder Richtung, zumindest die größeren. Das hätte also schon eine ganze Zahl von Bildpunkten in der Kamera bedeutet. Und man hätte das Gebäude erkennen können. Man brauchte mehr als einen Bildpunkt, um irgendetwas als Objekt erkennen zu können. Das war was ganz Neues. Die Viking-Bilder hatten nämlich typische Auflösungen von 60 bis 100 Meter pro Bildpunkt. Da wäre also ein Gebäude überhaupt nicht erst aufgetaucht. Mock jetzt, diese Kamera hatte diese extrem viel bessere Auflösung, eine Größenordnung besser. Und man hat auch gleich etwas entdeckt, was wieder mal einer kleinen Revolution gleichkam. Das waren die inzwischen, also zumindest in Marsforscherkreisen, berühmten sogenannten Gallis. Ein Gully ist eine Art Erosionsrinne, die man auf der Erde in fast allen Berggebieten findet. Eine schmale Rinne, durch die eindeutig Wasser runtergeflossen ist. Und unten hat das Wasser, das oben erodierte Material, abgelagert. Man hat also so eine Art zuerst oben Erosion, die Rinne, und unten bildet sich dann so ein Schwemmfächer. Das ist nichts Besonderes, auf der Erde gibt es überall. Besonders schön ist es zu sehen in Wüstengebieten. Und mir fällt jetzt gerade das Death Valley an. Da gibt es halt ganz besonders schöne solche Schwemmfächer und Gallis. Aber ansonsten auch nichts Besonderes. Auf dem Mars allerdings ist das schon etwas Besonderes, weil erstens weist es auf die Vergangenheit, die vergangene Existenz von Wasser hin. Und was das Ganze so extrem interessant gemacht hat, war, dass diese Gallis offensichtlich sehr, sehr jung sind in geologischer Hinsicht, was den Mars angeht. Das heißt, man hat kaum Einschlagskrater im Zusammenhang mit diesen Gallis gesehen. Und wenn kaum Einschlagskrater da sind, heißt das immer, eine Oberfläche ist sehr jung. Denn, das ist, glaube ich, ziemlich anschaulich, wenn sie länger einfach nur so rumliegt, dann gibt es mehr Zeit, dass immer mehr Mithyriten einschlagen. Es bilden sich immer mehr Einschlagskrater. Und zum Schluss hat man dann eine extrem stark bekraterte alte Oberfläche, wie zum Beispiel auf den Hochländern vom Mond.
Genau.
So, bei diesen Gallis ganz anders. Kaum Krater, also sehr jung. Wie jung genau, das war damals noch nicht klar. Es ist dann immer versucht worden, mit den hochauflösenden Bildern genauer einzuschränken. Ein paar Krater gab es ja doch. Und unser Kollege Dennis Reis aus mittlerweile Münster hat das genau nachgemessen. Seine Schätzung ist, dass manche von diesen Gallis nur ein paar hunderttausend Jahre alt sind. Zumindest die Endphase ihrer Entstehung. Andere Forscher haben das auch versucht nachzuvollziehen.
Hunderttausend Jahre.
Das ist gar nichts.
Das ist ja vorhin.
Das ist selbst auf der Erde nicht besonders viel. Und für Mars, einem Planeten, bei dem wir in vielen Bereichen der Oberfläche ein paar Milliarden Jahren zurückschauen können, ist das, als ob es gestern geschehen wäre. So, jetzt hat man...
Also wir haben sozusagen die Aktivitäten, die Flüsse quasi knapp verpasst überhaupt.
Sozusagen.
Hätte sich die Menschheit etwas schneller entwickelt.
Vor allen Dingen das Wichtige bei ein paar hunderttausend Jahren ist, dann kann niemand sagen, es wäre ein extremer Zufall, wenn man gerade jetzt ein paar Jahre nach dem letzten Zucker gelandet wäre. Dann muss man auch in Betracht sein, dass es ja vielleicht in ein paar hunderttausend Jahren oder auch übermorgen wieder losgehen könnte. Dass es so ein Zyklus gehen könnte. Man hat also das Rätsel gehabt, Wasser praktisch jetzt auf dem Mars, obwohl wir doch wissen, dass die Atmosphäre so dünn ist, dass Mars kalt ist, sodass Wasser eigentlich flüssig gar nicht existieren kann. Jedenfalls zumindest nicht über längere Zeit. Also wir haben sich diese Gallis gebildet, diese Erosionsrinnen, die auf der Erde durch flüssiges Wasser gebildet werden, wenn auf dem Mars flüssiges Wasser doch eigentlich physikalisch gar nicht stabil ist. Das war die Frage, die seit dieser Mars Global Surveyor Mission im Raum steht. Und um es gleich vorwegzunehmen, richtig beantwortet ist sie immer noch nicht. Die Forscher denken immer noch, Anfangszeichen verzweifelt drüber nach, wie kriegen wir denn jetzt flüssiges Wasser in ausreichender Menge dahin, dass Mars vor ein paar Tausend, paar Zehntausend, paar Hunderttausend Jahren noch so aktiv war, dass wir diese Erosionsrinnen ausspülen können.
Aber Wasser ist eigentlich die einzige Option. Also was anderes kommt nicht in Frage. Ich meine, auf den Titan gibt es irgendwie das Ganze mit Methan, aber dafür ist es dann wiederum nicht kalt genug.
Auf dem Mars gibt es keine wirklich plausible Alternative. Es muss irgendwas Flüssiges gewesen sein. Es haben einige Forscher darüber nachgedacht, ob das nicht irgendwie flüssiges CO2 sein könnte, weil die Mars-Oberfläche besteht ja aus CO2. Ist aber physikalisch eher noch schwieriger, weil flüssiges CO2, da müsste der Druck ja noch viel höher sein. Das geht ebenfalls sehr schnell in Gasverminkzustand über. Wenn überhaupt, dann ist es eine plausible Alternative, dass die Sachen im trockenen Zustand erzeugt worden sind. Durch Geröll-Lavinen oder irgendwelche, man sagt es auf Englisch Dry Granule Flows, also durch irgendwelche Granulan-Flies-Erscheinungen, wo keine Flüssigkeit im Spiel war, die sich aber als Flüssigkeit verhalten. Im Englischen gibt es da den Unterschied Liquid und Fluid. Also diese Sachen würden das Fließverhalten von einem Liquid haben, sie sind aber nicht Fluid.
Liquid ist, wenn es nass ist und Fluid ist, wenn es sich irgendwie bewegt.
Fluid ist ein Gas, ein Gas wäre auch in Fluid, es bewegt sich, es kann auch fließen. Eis kann auch fließen, aber Liquid ist wirklich nur, von den Phasen, von den Aggregatszuständen her.
So ein bisschen wie Instant-Tee, der da so...
Genau, oder eine Kieselinie oder irgendwas. Mittlerweile ist das Konsens. Es gibt wenige wirklich harte Hinweise darauf, dass das einfach trockene Fließerscheinungen sind.
Also muss es mal Wasser gegeben haben.
Es gibt eine Rettung sozusagen für die Fahrt. Also wie kriegt man das Wasser hin, wenn es doch physikalisch instabil ist? Wenn da also Wasser war, müsste das Klima anders gewesen sein. Dichter die Atmosphäre, wärmer. Wie kriegen wir jetzt ein Marsklima hin, das innerhalb von ein paar Hunderttausend Jahren schwankt? Dichter weniger stark, dichter weniger dicht? Die einzige wirklich denkbare Option ist die, dass das Klima sich ändert, weil die Achse vom Mars, die Rotationsachse, schwankt im Raum. Die Erdrotationsachse ist geneigt gegenüber der Ekliptik, der Bahn, in der die Erde um die Sonne sich dreht. Das ist der Grund, warum wir Jahreszeiten haben. Das weiß jeder, glaube ich, hoffentlich aus der Schule.
Der Mond hält das stabil.
Der Mond als großer Körper hält diese Neigung der Rotationsachse mehr oder weniger stabil.
Der Mars hat zwar Monde, aber die sind ja eher so lächerlich im Vergleich.
Die sind, was die Masse, auch ihre kombinierte Masse, angeht vollkommen lächerlich und können die Mars-Rotationsachse nicht stabilisieren. Sie schwankt, auch weil andere Himmelskörper einen Einfluss darauf ausüben. Jupiter zum Beispiel, insbesondere angeblich auch, was man mittlerweile von neuen Rechnungen hört, einige der großen Asteroiden, vielleicht auch die Erde. Jedenfalls, sie schwankt und sie schwankt beträchtlich. Sie schwankt zwischen einem gegenwärtigen Wert von 25 Grad in das eine Extrem hin bis zu 60 Grad, manche sagen noch stärker, und im anderen Extrem hin bis fast null. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass manchmal der Pol stärker und manchmal schwächer von der Sonne beschienen wird. Wenn die Neigung sehr hoch ist, wird er im Sommer sehr stark von der Sonne beschienen. Wenn die Neigung fast null ist, gibt es praktisch keinen Sommer und Winter mehr, dann wird er nur noch tangential beschienen.
Und wie ist es derzeit?
Derzeit ist es 25 Grad ungefähr, fast zufällig wie auf der Erde. Das heißt, es wäre so eine Art Mittelstellung. So, jetzt ist die Idee. Wir wissen ja, dass auf dem Mars die Polkappen Wasser und Kohlendioxid speichern in Eisform. Woher wissen wir das? Das wissen wir, weil wir es erstens sehen und zweitens durch Spektroskopie-Untersuchungen auch analysiert haben, was für Material es ist. Also die weißen Kappen.
Von der Erde aus oder jetzt von einem dieser Orbiter-Missionen?
Beides. In Mars Express gab es und gibt es ein Spektrometer-Omega, das hat Wassereis als Spektrum eindeutig in den Polkappen nachgewiesen. Es gibt auch andere, vorher schon gab es starke Hinweise darauf, dass da Wasser zu finden ist. Und dieses Wasser bildet auch, das weiß man mittlerweile, den Hauptteil der Polkappen. Das war auch lange Zeit nicht so klar, ist das ganze Eis, das dort offensichtlich rumliegt, das sieht man in Bildern, man sieht es auch in den Höhendaten von dem Laseraltimeter. Da liegt ganz schön was rum an Material und jetzt weiß man, das meiste davon ist tatsächlich Wassereis. So, und wenn jetzt der Pull durch eine stärkere Neigung der Rotationsachse...
Wie viel Eis ist das so? Ist das genauso viel Wasser, wie man das auch auf der Erde hat? Dass das wirklich, wenn es jetzt alles geschmolzen wäre, sofort Seen und Ozeane bilden würde?
Nein, es ist bei Weitem nicht so viel. Es ist auch nicht relativ so viel wie auf der Erde. Ich glaube, eine Zahl, an die ich mich erinnere, ist, dass in der Nordpolkappe ungefähr die Eismenge von Grönland gespeichert ist. Wenn man das jetzt alles gleichmäßig über den Mars verteilt, dann sind das, nach dieser Zahl habe ich leider nicht auswendig im Kopf, aber ich glaube nur ein paar Meter. Das nennt man dann Global Equivalent Layer.
Ein paar Meter flüssiges Wasser.
Ein paar Meter, es wäre eine gleichmäßige Schicht über die ganze Marsoberfläche verteilt von ein paar Metern. Vielleicht 10 Meter, 16 Meter.
Aber es ist auch nicht nichts.
Es ist nicht nichts, aber ein Ozean ist es auch nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall wäre es schon ein ordentlicher Teich.
Und dieses Wasser könnte man also theoretisch mobilisieren, indem man den Pol Richtung Sonne kippt im Sommer durch eine Schwankung der Rotationsachse. Dann würde die Sonne draufknallen, Wasser würde in die Atmosphäre übergehen und könnte dann woanders, sprich weiter Richtung der niedrigen Breiten hin, Richtung Equator hin, als Niederschlag wieder runterkommen, vorzugsweise als Schnee. Und wenn der Schnee dann dort schmilzt, weil er zum Beispiel an einem Sonnenzugewandten Hang fällt oder weil er im Untergrund, weiß ich, da gibt es einen Effekt, der heißt Solid State Greenhouse Effect, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht in die Halle zu gehen. Es gibt schon Möglichkeiten, wie man dann in einem solchen Szenario den Schnee zum Schmelzen bringen könnte, auch wenn man es nicht... Es ist gerade Gegenstand der Forschung, wie man ihn und in welcher Menge ihn zum Schmelzen bringt. Und das könnte dann verursacht haben, dass sich diese Erosionsrinnen bilden.
Weil dann halt wirklich Wasser anfängt, von den Hängen zu fließen etc.
Weil dann Wasser in diesen Breiten da ist. Jetzt gibt es ja dort, wo die Erosionsrinnen sind, kaum Wasser. Kann schon sein, dass da im Winter mal sich ein bisschen raureif bildet, aber das ist nicht sehr viel. Für die Erosionsrinnen brauchen wir mehr. Und dieses Szenario der Rotationsachsen-Schwankung und der damit einhergehenden Klimaveränderung innerhalb kurzer Zeit, auch in jüngerer Vergangenheit, könnte möglicherweise eine Erklärung dafür sein.
Aber es ist jetzt noch nicht, es klang für mich so ein bisschen so, als wäre das noch so eine Theorie, dass diese Schwankung der Achse wirklich so extrem ist.
Das ist eine, das ist ein Modell. Ich würde es nicht Theorie nennen, es ist ein Modell eines Menschen, der sich mit Himmelsmechanik auskennt. Der hat es ausgerechnet, dass es so sein sollte. Dieses Modell wird nicht von allen geteilt, weil manche Leute sagen, so einfach ist es auch wieder nicht, dass man eine Rotationsachse ständig hin und her schwankt. Dabei geht ja, dafür braucht man Energie und Energie würde dann durch Dissipation in dem Körper verloren gehen. Ich bin da kein Experte, was das geothetisch alles bedeutet. Aber es ist nicht jeder von diesem Modell und dem damit sozusagen einhergehenden Klimawechsel wirklich überzeugt. Sollte dieses Modell sich aus irgendeinem Grund als falsch herausstellen, dass die Achse nicht so stark schwankt, hätten alle die, und dazu zählen ein paar von meinen Kollegen und auch ich, ein großes Problem, die bereits in die Richtung spekuliert haben, das Modell, das nicht von uns kommt, wäre die Erklärung für Beobachtungen, die wir als Geologen machen und die flüssiges Wasser erfordern.
Okay, also alles andere als eine gesicherte These, ist aber auf jeden Fall etwas, was genug Gehalt hat, um da auch schon mal gleich weiterzudehnen.
Das ist im Augenblick die beste Arbeitshypothese, die wir haben.
Das heißt, der Mars ist so ein bisschen so ein schlummernder Riese, macht so den Eindruck, potentiell.
In seinen wissenschaftlichen Potenzials auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber auch so, was seine Energie betrifft. Weil jetzt schaut man so drauf und denkt sich so, naja, sieht ja alles total tot aus irgendwie. Marsmännchen gibt es auch nicht. Keine Gebäude, keine Turnhallen, nichts gesehen. So kann aber durchaus sein, dass wenn auch in einem Zeitraum, der für uns überhaupt nicht denkbar ist, keine Ahnung, in vier, 500.000 Jahren wieder irgendetwas kippt und er sich sozusagen selbst erweckt und sich so eine temporäre Atmosphäre schafft, die dann eben auch wieder zu Innovationen führt.
Es gibt auch noch andere Hinweise darauf, dass er zumindest schlafend ist, ein Riese, wird er nie im Vergleich zur Erde, aber ein Planet, der bis in die jüngste Vergangenheit aktiver darauf deuten, auch Untersuchungen hin, die ich zum Beispiel gemacht habe. Wir haben uns vulkanische Oberflächen auf dem Mars angeschaut, Lava-Ströme, kleine Schildvulkane, und haben dort die Krater gezählt, um sie in ein absolutes Alter umzuwandeln. Und das, was wir daraus gekriegt haben, deutet darauf hin, dass die vulkanische Vergangenheit auf dem Mars, also etwas, was eindeutig von innen kommt, wofür wir keine Achsenschwankungen brauchen und nichts, dass die bis in die letzten 10er-Millionen Jahre angedauert hat und vielleicht sogar noch länger angedauert hat, was einige Untersuchungen an ganz vereinzelten Lava-Strömen hinweist. Und das haben wir so interpretiert, und das würde ich auch nach wie vor so stehen lassen, ist, wenn wir vulkanische Aktivität über Milliarden von Jahren haben, bis in die letzten paar Millionen Jahre, dann gibt es keinen Grund anzunehmen, dass wir jetzt genau dann zum Mars geflogen werden, wenn sie endgültig aufgehört hätte. So ein bisschen wie bei dem Wasser. Ich würde es für absolut plausibel halten, wenn der Mars vulkanisch zumindest potenziell nach wie vor aktiv ist. Und wenn der nächste Ausbruch nur ein Jahr, zehn Jahre, 100 Jahre, eine Million Jahre, zehn Millionen Jahre in der Zukunft vor uns liegt. Ich kann es natürlich nicht genauer eingrenzen, aber ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, es liegt im Bereich des Möglichen, dass da nach wie vor genügend Energie im Inneren ist, die zur Aufschmelzung und zur Vulkanismus führt.
Kann aber nur sein, dass die Prozesse so langsam sind, dass selbst 50 Jahre Forschung da sozusagen nichts mitbekommen haben.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die Ruhephasen zwischen Vulkanausbrüchen 1000 Jahre sind, was immer noch extrem kurz wäre. Wir haben auf der Erde Vulkane, die brechen sozusagen schlafend für mehr als 1000 Jahre und dann brechen sie wieder aus. Alles schon dagewiesen. Und auf dem Mars wären 1000 Jahre gar nichts. Also wir müssten aber noch ganz schön lange Marsforschung betreiben, um eine vorher-nachher-Beobachtung mit 1000 Jahren Differenz zu kriegen.
Und wenn da jetzt morgen ein Vulkan losgeht, würde das sofort auffallen oder ist die Überwachung jetzt auch nicht so?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Nein, es würde erstmal nicht sofort auffallen. Denn wir nehmen den Mars ja nicht alle paar Tage global mit Bildern auf. Und schon gleich kann ich in der Auflösung dies dann bräuchte. Denn es gibt ja wahrscheinlich nicht gleich einen Vulkanersbruch, der den halben Mars überflutet, sondern irgendwo ein Lavastrom von vielleicht ein paar Kilometer Länge, ein paar hundert Meter Breite. Aber es wäre vermutlich das äußerste der Gefühle. Also mit Bildern müsste man schon sehr großes Glück haben, wenn man dazu vielleicht dann drüber fliegt und eine Vorher-Nachher-Betrachtung anstellt. Vielversprechender wäre eine Beobachtung durch niedrig auflösende thermale Daten. Wenn man also einen Infrarotapparat hätte, ein Spektrometer, das im thermalen Infrarot arbeitet, und man sieht dann, dass es irgendwo eine extrem heiße Stelle auf dem Mars gibt. Man würde nicht erkennen, dass es ein Lavastrom ist. Aber man würde erkennen, dass da in der Gegend die Oberfläche viel heißer ist als vielleicht vor zehn Jahren. Und das wäre dann wie eine Art Taschenlampe, die danach schreit, kommt, fotografiert uns näher, schaut uns genauer an.
Aber solche Beobachtungsposten gibt es in dem Sinne derzeit noch gar nicht.
So ein Spektrometer gibt es im Augenblick eigentlich nicht auf dem Mars. Nein, leider. Es gibt zwar im nahen Infrarotbereich Spektrometer, die arbeiten. Und Temes, das ist ein Infrarot, das ist ein Spektrometer, der arbeitet auf dem Mars. Oder die Seesonde, die nach wie vor aktiv ist. Aber ich weiß nicht, mit welcher Intensität derzeit noch auf globaler Basis den Mars aufnimmt.
Und wenn man hier von der Erde aus schauen würde, zum Beispiel hier mit dem Sophia, mit dem fliegenden Infrarotauge.
Dann wäre es wirklich eine Frage, der Größe dieses thermalen Signals, das da auf dem Mars zu sehen ist. Ich bezweifle, dass Sophia dafür ausgelegt ist, sowas zu entdecken. Da müsste man schon wirklich näher hinkommen.
Also kann sein, dass da durchaus was abgeht und wir merken es bloß noch gerade nicht.
Ist durchaus möglich. Eine vielleicht andere Möglichkeit wäre, wenn so ein Vulkan ausbricht, entlässt er ja auch viel Gas in die Atmosphäre. Alle möglichen Gase. Wasser, Kohlendioxid, Schwefeldioxid. Und das Gas verteilt sich dann in der Atmosphäre. Das ist in zweierlei Hinsicht interessant, wenn es wirklich relativ viel Vulkanausbrüche in der jüngeren Vergangenheit gegeben hat, wären das ja auch Beiträge für die Atmosphäre, die ein bisschen was von diesem Wasser erklären könnten, das wir auf der Oberfläche beobachten. Und zweitens könnte man dann ja sagen, die Atmosphäre verändert sich durch diese Vulkanausbrüche kurzfristig und diejenigen Instrumente, die jetzt nicht lokal nach irgendwelchen Sachen forschen, sondern global die Atmosphäre anschauen, könnten vielleicht eine Signatur von Vulkanausbrüchen in der globalen Atmosphäre und ihrer Zusammensetzung erkennen. Das wäre eine andere Möglichkeit, mit der man vielleicht indirekt große Vulkanausbrüche feststellen könnte.
Aber wenn es nur hier und da so ein bisschen blubbert?
Ja, dann verteilt sich das, glaube ich, so hinreichend in der Atmosphäre, dass man wahrscheinlich keine wirklich signifikante Änderung in der globalen Zusammensetzung erkennen kann.
Ja, das große Bild, das will ich auch gerne noch mal ein bisschen verschärfen. Jetzt interessiert mich natürlich nochmal, wie das jetzt eigentlich mit den Missionen weitergegangen ist. Also wir hatten ja Pathfinder und dann später den Global Surveyor als Mission, die jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, den Erkenntnisreichtum weiter angereichert haben. Was kam danach? Wie hat sich das Bild des Marses dadurch weiter noch verschärft?
Dadurch wurde die Begeisterung immer größer. Die Gallis waren auch ein Riesenthema die ganze Zeit. Global Surveyor hat noch was anderes Interessantes gefunden. Ein Delta von einem Fluss gebildet. Ein schöner Hinweis darauf, dass allerdings dann in größerer Vergangenheit. Wasser in so großer Menge vorhanden war, dass es Flüsse und auch Seen gebildet hat. Dieses Delta hat sich offensichtlich am Rand eines Sees gebildet. Es ist dann also weitergegangen mit den Missionen. Die NASA ist nicht von ihrem ursprünglichen Bahn abgerückt. Mars Odyssey war die nächste Mission. Mit einigen interessanten Instrumenten an Bord, wieder eine Kamera, wieder ein Spektrometer und so weiter. Und dann kam Mars Express, die erste europäische Mission zu einem Planeten. Wenn sie so bezeichnet wird, dann unterschlägt man immer, dass die Sowjets ja auch Europäer waren und sie einige erfolgreiche Sonden zu Planeten hatten, wenn auch nicht zu Mars, dann zu Venus. Aber egal, gemeint ist dann natürlich immer die erste ESA-Sonde zu einem Planeten. Und das besonders Schöne daran war, erstens man konnte die Instrumente, die als Duplikate noch von der russischen Mars 96-Mission übrig waren, verwerten. Das war eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum diese Mission ins Leben gerufen wurde. Die Instrumente waren alle schon da, man brauchte bloß noch, in Anführungszeichen, bloß noch eine Raumsonde. Und die ESA hat sich dann die Sichtweise zu eigen gemacht, hat relativ schnell, deswegen Mars Express, die Sonde hingestellt. Die Instrumente waren schon da, zumindest zum Großteil. Man hat dann noch ein Radargerät draufgebaut, ein Novum in der Marsforschung. Und dann ging es los, 2003, und besonders schön, es war die erste Sonde, die probiert worden ist, zu einem Planeten zu fliegen von der ESA. Und sie hat auch gleich wunderbar geklappt. Und seitdem ist sie aktiv, bis zum heutigen Tag. Mars Express hat auch in einiger Hinsicht wunderbare Ergebnisse geliefert. Als wichtigstes muss man glaube ich sagen, dass Mars Express einige Minerale auf der Oberfläche von Mars nachgewiesen hat, von deren Existenz man bis dahin nichts gewusst hatte. Man hatte zwar darüber spekuliert, dass es zum Beispiel Sulfate oder insbesondere Tonminerale auf dem Mars geben müsste. Denn solche Minerale bilden sich, wenn man Basalt, von dem man weiß, dass es auf der Mars-Oberfläche vorhanden ist, wenn man Basalt in Kontakt mit Wasser bringt. Man wusste, Basalt ist da. Man wusste, Wasser war da. Also müsste man auch Verwitterungsprodukte von dem Basalt finden. Und das sind zum Beispiel Salze oder Tonminerale. Und Mars Express hatte einen Spektrometer an Bord, Omega.
Also Basalt, muss man mal kurz so sagen, ist im Wesentlichen so das Gestein, was sich so aus vulkanischen Prozessen heraus überhaupt erst mal ergibt.
Ja, hätte ich sagen sollen, Basalt ist das, was als erstes entsteht, wenn man den Mantel eines Planeten aufschmilzt und das aufgeschmolze Material, sprich das Magma, an die Oberfläche bringt, wenn es an der Oberfläche ist, nennt man es Lava. Wenn die erkaltet, dann hat man Basalt. Das ist das gängigste Gestein auf der Erde. Die ganzen Ozeanböden bestehen aus Basalt. Aber auch auf vielen anderen Vulkanen, Hawaii oder Ätnau, überall gibt es Basalt.
Aber dann durch diese Verwitterung und die anderen Einflüsse und den Kontakt mit der Atmosphäre...
Auf der Erde alles mögliche andere draus. Man wusste, also auf dem Mond hat man auch Basalt, auf dem Venus hat man auch Basalt. Das passiert einfach, wenn man den Mantel eines Planeten aufschmilzt. Auf dem Mars erwartet man also Verwitterungsprodukte, weil es dort auch Wasser gibt, so wie auf der Erde. Aber man konnte sie nicht richtig nachweisen. Man hat ein paar Hinweise über die Viking-Sonden schon gehabt, aber nichts wirklich extrem Greifbares. Und Omega, dieses Spektrometer, konnte im sichtbaren und im nahen Infrarotbereich die charakteristischen Signaturen von solchen Mineralen aufspüren. Und nicht nur aufspüren, im Sinne von, man hat sie auf dem Mars, sondern sie konnte es auch kartieren. Das heißt, man konnte schauen, dort gibt es sie, dort gibt es sie nicht. Deswegen konnte man also Karten von sogenannten Alterationsmineralen bilden, die durch die Alteration von Basalt entstanden sind. Und weil diese Mineralen ja auf Wasser hinweisen und zum Teil sogar Wasser in ihren Kristallstrukturen eingebunden haben, war das der nächste Riesenschritt vorwärts in der Marsgeologie. Man hatte jetzt nicht nur die Ausgangsgestelle, die Basalte, sondern man hatte auch die Produkte, die ein eindeutiger Hinweis dafür waren, dass dieser Basalt mit Wasser in Berührung gekommen war. So und diese Stellen, wo man diese Mineralen findet, sind natürlich dann auch die absoluten Zielstellen für diejenigen Missionen, die dann landen können und sich die Geschichte vom Wasser in diesen Mineralen genauer anschauen wollen und vielleicht sogar nach Leben suchen wollen, die im Zusammenhang mit diesem Wasser und diesen Mineralen existiert haben könnten.
Das heißt, Mars Express hat sozusagen so ein bisschen die Basis geliefert für neue Zielsuchungen.
Ja, absolut. Mars Express hat gezeigt, dass es diese Mineralen gibt und hat gezeigt, wo es sie gibt. Eine folgende Mission dann, die Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter Mission der NASA, hatte ein noch besseres Spektrometer an Bord, besser im Hinblick auf die spektrale Auflösung, also wie fein man die Wellenlänge untersuchen kann und besser auch im Sinne der räumlichen Auflösung, man kann kleinere Vorkommen entdecken. Und die Teams von Omega und Chrism haben sehr genau zusammengearbeitet, sehr gut zusammengearbeitet. Deswegen sozusagen kann man da Omega...
Also Omega ist das Instrument von Mars Express, das die Wader erkennt.
Das Instrument, das gezeigt hat, wo sie sind und Chrism kann sie jetzt noch genauer untersuchen. Das war eine der großen Leistungen von Mars Express. Eine andere war, dass man ein Radar dabei hatte, mit dem man nicht nur die Oberfläche, sondern auch unter die Oberfläche schauen kann. Das ist der entscheidende Vorteil von Radar. Man kann abhängig von der Wellenlänge des Radars in den Untergrund hineinblicken, wo die Radarstrahlen dann, die Radarsignale von sogenannten Grenzflächen reflektiert werden. Man schaut also in den Untergrund und wenn es im Untergrund eine Grenzfläche gibt, eine solche wäre zum Beispiel der Grundwasserspiegel, dann sieht man, dass in so und so vielen Metern oder Kilometern Tiefe, da ändert sich der Untergrund weil zum Beispiel Grundwasser da ist. Und das wäre natürlich super, wenn man so etwas feststehen kann.
Also man kann Wasser...
Das war die große Hoffnung. Man will den Grundwasserspiegel auf dem Mars oder den Bodeneisspiegel, wenn es in Form von Eis vorliegt, mit diesem Radar kartieren. Es war ein sehr langweiliges Radar oder ist ein sehr langweiliges Radar, es funktioniert ja nach wie vor. Denn über Modellvorstellungen hat man gedacht, man muss schon ein bisschen rein in den Untergrund, um wirklich Wasser zu finden oder Eis. Ganz knapp an der Oberfläche, also in den ersten 10, 20 Metern, in den ersten 100 Metern, da ist es wahrscheinlich mittlerweile nicht mehr anzutreffen. Weiterin aber vielleicht doch. Deswegen hat man dieses Radar mit langen Wellenlängen konzipiert. Es hat sich gezeigt, dass sich nichts gezeigt hat. Leider hat man diese erhoffte globale oder zumindest regionalen Grundwasserspiegel oder Bodeneisspiegel nicht entdecken können. Bis zum heutigen Tag nicht. Das heißt aber nicht, dass das Radar ein Misserfolg war. Man hat andere interessante Sachen machen können. Man hat z.B. ganz entscheidend und ganz wichtig die Polkappen mit ihrem Eis, die konnte man wunderbar durchleuchten mit diesem Radar. Man hat also eine mittlerweile sehr gute Vorstellung davon, wie die dreidimensionale Struktur dieser Polkappen, wie dick die wirklich sind, was da drinnen ist. Und man hat also, ob Wasser, ob Eis, wie viel davon, wie viel Staub da noch, das kann man mittlerweile alles wunderbar nachschauen. Zumindest an der Südpolkappe. An der Nordpolkappe ist man jetzt gerade dabei, die mit genügend, mit hinreichend zahlreichen Beobachtungen zu untersuchen mit diesem Radar. Das war der bis jetzt, würde ich sagen, größte Erfolg dieses Radars. Es gibt auch noch andere Formationen auf der Marsoberfläche, in die das Radar relativ gut eindringen konnte, weil sie entweder porös oder eisreich sind. Und das waren auch schöne Ergebnisse, die durch dieses Instrument da erzielt worden sind. Es gibt natürlich noch andere ganz tolle Instrumente auf Mars Express. Unsere Kamera hier in Adlershof gebaut.
Das HRC. Ich mach's hier, das mach ich falsch.
Das machen viele.
Ich weiß gar nicht warum, aber...
Vielleicht ist das andere eingängiger, keine Ahnung. Aber bei uns hat es natürlich nach 10 Jahren automatisiert. Also HRC, die High Resolution Stereo Camera. Die hat nicht die Auflösung, die die Mockkamera vorher schon hatte. Das heißt, wir haben nicht die Zielsetzung, Sachen zu entdecken als Objekte, die noch keiner vorher gesehen hat.
Die Mockkamera von dem Global Surveyor.
Genau, das hat man vorher schon abgehakt. Da spielt natürlich auch rein, dass wir eigentlich schon 96 hätten fliegen wollen. Dann wären wir die ersten mit so einer tollen Aufnahme. Aber glücklicherweise ist die eigentliche Stärke unserer Kamera nach wie vor einzigartig, das ist nämlich die Stereo-Kapazität. Wir können aus den Stereobildern die Topographie der Mars-Oberfläche mit einer Genauigkeit ableiten, insbesondere was die horizontale Auflösung angeht, die mit dem vorher schon bestehenden Daten des Laser-Altimeters auf der Mars-Global Surveyor-Emission nicht möglich sind. Wir zielen darauf ab, das global zu machen. Wir können also die Oberfläche extrem gut dreidimensional darstellen und haben als weiteren Vorteil, dass wir nicht nur die Höhen-Daten-Oberfläche haben, sondern wir haben ja auch noch die Bilder dazu, die genau drauf passen. Wir sehen also wirklich für jeden Bildpunkt, wie hoch ist er über einem bestimmten Referenz-Level gelegen und vor allen Dingen, wie hoch ist er im Vergleich zu den Bildpunkten daneben. Wie ist da die Hangneigung zum Beispiel eine extrem wichtige Sache, wenn man geologische Prozesse analysieren will? Das ist die Stärke unseres Instruments. Und wie es im Augenblick ausschaut, wird die auch von keinem anderen Instrument in absehbarer Zukunft wiederholt werden können oder gar verbessert werden können.
Unser Instrument, das heißt das HRSC, ist hier auch mitentwickelt worden.
Das Instrument, die wurzelreichen bis nach Oberpfaffenhofen zurück damals noch. Es war schon als Instrument für die russischen Missionen –zuerst für die sowjetischen Missionen im Gespräch, dann für die russische Mars 96-Mission –werden dann den großen Tiefpunkt, der sind 96 als unsere schöne Kamera mitsamt der russischen Mission in den Pazifik gestürzt ist. Aber zum Glück gab es Mars Express, wo man das Duplikat der Kamera fliegen konnte.
Ah ja.
Übrigens genauso ein Duplikat wie Omega, dieses Spektrometer. Also diese Instrumente hätten alle schon fast ein Jahrzehnt früher revolutionäre Wissenschaft gemacht, wenn das damals geklappt hätte.
Dann ist es aber zweimal gebaut worden.
Da zahlt es sich dann aus, dass man die hohen Entwicklungskosten auf zwei Instrumente umlegt. Man gibt also vergleichsweise nur noch ein bisschen mehr Geld aus. Hat aber dann ein Duplikat und falls was schief geht, war nicht alles umsonst.
Ja.
Gut, HSC war ein weiteres Beispiel für schöne Instrumente auf Mars Express. Eines, an dem wir hier nach wie vor intensiv arbeiten. Wir betreuen die Kamera, wir betreiben sie und sind also insofern dafür verantwortlich, was sie für Bilder macht und zurücksendet. Und wir werten die Bilder natürlich auch hier im Institut aus. Und dann gab es noch ein paar andere Instrumente, Spektrometer, die insbesondere für die Atmosphäre gebaut worden sind. Um die Atmosphäre des Mars, erstens was die Zusammensetzung betrifft, aber auch was ihre vertikale Struktur betrifft, genau untersuchen zu können.
Diese Daten sind ja dann sozusagen auch wirklich die Quelle für diese großartigen dreidimensionalen Eindrücke, die man jetzt bekommen kann vom Mars. Das kommt im Prinzip von dieser Kamera.
Genau, viele dieser Animationen, wenn man wieder mal über einen Krater hinwegfliegt oder irgendwie an einen Vulkan vorbei oder in die Wallis Marinäres hinein, das ist eine riesige Schlucht, die stammen von den HSC-Daten. Man sieht ja dort Bilder, aber was erforderlich ist, um sie so dreidimensional zu animieren, sind die Höhen-Daten. Wir können mit unserem Instrument beides auf einmal erzeugen und sind dann in der Lage, am Computer die Daten so zu manipulieren, dass man den Eindruck eines Überflugs bekommt. Also selbst wenn man im Flugzeug auf dem Mars.
Ich hatte das ja auch schon hier kurz angesprochen, Raumzeit 44. Also eigentlich ging es um den Merkur, da habe ich mich hier mit Deman Spohn, dem Leiter vom Institut, unterhalten. Das war ausgerechnet die Woche der Landung des Mars-Space-Laboratoriums, also der Curiosity Rover. Natürlich mussten wir da gleich drüber reden, weil das natürlich ein großes Ereignis ist. Wir sollten ja auch gleich nochmal drüber reden. Aber da klang dann auch an, dass natürlich das HRSC an der Stelle auch einen großen Einfluss hatte, was eben insbesondere diesen viel bestaunten Film, der das Drama des Abstiegs dieser Mission auf den Planeten beschrieb.
Da liegen unsere Höhendaten dahinter.
Kommen wir vielleicht nochmal zu den letzten Missionen. Haben wir die Orbiter jetzt schon alle erwähnt? Also MRO ist noch unterwegs, der Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter?
Ja, der hat als erwähnenswertes Instrument eine Kamera an Bord, die 30 Zentimeter pro Bildpunkt erreicht. Also damit können wir jetzt nicht nur Gebäude aufnehmen, damit könnten wir auch den Tisch als solchen erkennen, an dem wir gerade hier sitzen. Für die Zuhörer, der ist vielleicht zweieinhalb Meter lang, eineinhalb Meter breit. Und da können wir schon einige Bildpunkte mit 30 mal 30 Zentimeter draufsetzen. Das ist ungefähr die Auflösung, die viele terrestrische Spionagekameras auch haben. 30 Zentimeter pro Bildpunkt. Das reicht zum Beispiel schon, um Lastwagen oder Panzer oder gar Schiffe zu erkennen. Soweit ich weiß, ist das auch die gleiche Firma, die die Kamera für Mars gebaut hat, die auch viele der amerikanischen Spionagekameras baut.
Also wird sozusagen die maximal mögliche Präzision eingesetzt.
Das ist jetzt so ziemlich das Maximale dessen, was zumindest im zivilen Bereich noch nach außen erlaubt wird. Und man muss auch sagen, ist es auch das Maximale eigentlich, was man braucht. Denn mehr als 30 Zentimeter, das hat sich jetzt durch die Mission gezeigt, ist in vielen Bereichen der Mars-Oberfläche gar nicht nötig. Es ist sogar so, dass die 30 Zentimeter oft schon gar nicht mehr bringen, als was man durch die Mockkamera schon erreicht hat. Denn als Beispiel, wenn sie einen Lavastrom haben, der größtenteils mit Staub bedeckt ist, da sehen sie nun mal nicht mehr, ob sie mit einem Meter, 30 Zentimeter oder auch mit 5 Zentimetern hinschauen, würde sie sehen, nur Staub. Das bringt irgendwann nichts mehr. Wenn man über 30 Zentimeter hinausgehen will, dann wird man das machen, was jetzt eh zurzeit schon der Trend ist. Man wird wirklich versuchen, mit einer Landessonde runterzukommen und dann dorthin zu fahren und es dafür dann ganz genau anzuschauen.
Aber um Bilder von dieser Landessonde wiederum zu machen, ist die Rohrauflösung natürlich ganz vormutabel.
Dann ist es natürlich super und ich will damit auch nicht sagen, dass die 30 Zentimeter vollkommen nutzlos sind. Ganz im Gegenteil, es hängt ganz davon ab, was man sich anschaut. Es gibt auf dem Mars geschichtete Ablagerungen, die zum Beispiel jetzt das Ziel von dem Curiosity Rover sind, zu dem wir noch kommen werden. Und solche Sachen sind extrem wunderbar zu beobachten mit diesen 30 Zentimeter pro Bilderpunkt. Insbesondere, wenn wenig Staub drauf liegt, dann kann man da extrem schön anschauen, wie ist die Schichtlagerung, wie dick sind die Schichten, sind sie gegeneinander verkippt, was uns viel über die Ablagerungsprozesse erzählt. Für sowas ist die Sache ideal. Also 30 Zentimeter pro Bildpunkt, ja, aber nicht global. Und so wird es natürlich auch gemacht. Man kann mit so einer hohen Auflösung im Mars nicht global abfotografieren. Da müsste man so viele Terabytes runter senden, dass selbst eine Riesenantenne von Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter überfordert wäre. Und übrigens auch die Leute, die sich das dann alles hier anschauen müssten, da müsste man so viel Geld für Wissenschaftler spendieren. So viel Stellen gibt es nicht.
Ja, die Datenmenge wird natürlich dann auch enorm.
Die wird irgendwann nicht mehr handhabbar.
Man findet ja die Nadel nicht unbedingt besser, indem man sich noch mehr Heu schafft.
Das ist also, würde ich mal sagen, mit dieser Kamera ist das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht, was Auflösung angeht. Man verwendet sie jetzt hauptsächlich dafür, solche Sachen wie diese Ablagerungen anzuschauen und weniger, um Sachen wie vulkanische Oberflächen anzuschauen. Dafür hat sie sich jetzt nicht so toll erwiesen. Dafür umso besser bei solchen Sachen wie Ablagen oder auch wie dieses Delta, von dem ich vorher gesprochen habe. Davon gibt es mittlerweile ganz tolle Bilder. Das ist also diese Kamera. Ansonsten hat dieser Reconnaissance Orbiter noch das schon erwähnte Spektrometer an Bord. Es gibt dort auch ein Radar, kurzwellig, also für flache Sachen unter der Oberfläche. Aber ich glaube, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht genau drauf eingehen. Das hat jetzt auch noch nicht so den super neuen Erkenntnis gegeben, soweit ich das beurteilen kann, dass man sich erhofft hätte.
Warum sollten wir noch mal klarmachen? Wir befinden uns jetzt hier in den letzten zehn Jahren. Also Mars Express ist ja 2001 gestartet, seit 2003 im Betrieb.
2003 gestartet und 2004 angekommen und im Betrieb. Das weiß ich ganz genau.
Mars Express erreichte den Planeten 2003, genau.
2003 ist er im Juni gestartet.
Genau, ich hab mich gerade mit irgendwas verwechselt. Und der MRO, Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter, 2005 los und 2006 angekommen. Also es ist sozusagen alles innerhalb der letzten zehn Jahre passiert.
Relativ neu.
Genau. Und in diesen Zeitraum fällt ja dann auch das zweite Rover-Experiment, also das nächste Länder-Experiment von der NASA, Spirit und Opportunity. Und ich erinnere mich auch noch ganz gut an die Zeit damals. Das war auch so mal wieder so ein Moment, wo Raumfahrt auch so auf eine ganz spezielle Art und Weise von der Öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen wird. Das haben wir jetzt auch beim MSL wieder gesehen. Aber dann auch gleich so diese kuriose Doppelmission. Also man hat nicht gleich nicht nur einen Rover dahingeschickt, sondern gleich zwei. Warum eigentlich? Because we can?
Ja, das war schon auch ein Hintergedanke. Die Entwicklungskosten in dem Sinn sind die gleichen, weil es einen oder zwei baut. Und zwei wurden gewählt, einfach um das Risiko zu minimieren, dass bei einem was schief geht. Denn es war ja wieder eine ganz neue Dimension der Rover-Landung. Passt bei einer Schuhschachtel. Und die jetzt, die waren schon sehr viel größer. Das sind schon Geräte, die, was weiß ich...
So schwerer.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Damit wir entsparen übervorder mit diesen Ausdehnungen. Die hatten schon so eineinhalb bis zwei Meter in jeder Richtung. Und die Kamera ist eineinhalb Meter über der Oberfläche ungefähr. Also das sind schon große Geräte. Die beiden waren natürlich eine andere Größenordnung, auch finanziell, als Mars Express. Muss man ehrlicherweise zugeben. Und sie sind an zwei sehr verschiedenen Oberflächen niedergegangen, um dort jeweils nach Wasser zu suchen. Die eine Landestelle hatte man sich ausgesucht auf Grundlage von Bildern, also Morphologie. Und die andere Stelle hatte man sich ausgesucht auf Grundlage von Mineralologie. Also Zusammensetzung. Da war natürlich jetzt spannend, was ist sozusagen die bessere Methode, eine Landestelle zu suchen.
Leider lagen ja die Daten von Mars Express zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht vor.
Nein, wir sind gleichzeitig losgeflogen. Es war die gleiche Startmöglichkeit. Man kann nur alle zwei Jahre zu Mars fliegen durch die Konstellation der Planeten. Wir sind gleichzeitig losgeflogen und natürlich auch gleichzeitig angekommen. Und deswegen gab es nicht die Daten von Omega zu den mineralogischen Befunden, die jetzt vorliegen. Damals ist man noch auf Grundlage von TESS dahin geflogen zu einer Landesstelle. TESS ist ein Thermalerspektrometer, der dort Hematit nachgewiesen hat. Das ist ein Eisenmineral, das sich zusammen mit Wasser bildet.
Also TESS ist auch eine...
TESS ist ein Thermal Emission Spectrometer. Das ist ein NASA-Instrument auf Mars Odyssey. Ja, man kommt mittlerweile schon völlig durcheinander bei so vielen Orbiter, so vielen Missionen. Nur für Insider nachvollziehbar, was es da alles gibt und was wie viel gebracht hat. Gut, fangen wir mit dem Spirit Rover an, der in einem Krater niedergegangen ist, bei dem die Wissenschaftler gedacht hatten, da sehen wir, dass ein Tal in diesem Krater mündet. Und da gehen wir optimistisch davon aus, dass dieses Tal viel Sediment in den Krater reingespült hat. Da war ein See, der ist dann ausgetrocknet, das Sediment bildet den jetzigen Kraterboden. Also Top-Nachweismöglichkeiten für die Prozesse, die Wasser im Fluss transport und dann auch in einem See bietet. Und auch wenn diese Rover keine Möglichkeit hatten, Leben nachzuweisen, aber es hat immer irgendwie so ein bisschen mitgespielt in so einem See, könnte doch auch Leben gewesen sein. Und das liegt jetzt so als Fossilien oder Mikrofossilien in diesen Seesedimenten.
Was konnten die denn nachweisen?
Die konnten Minerale und Elemente nachweisen, die Merrover. Sie hatten also einen Spektrometer dabei. Den Mössbauer-Spektrometer, ganz wichtig, der kann Minerale nachweisen, sofern sie Eisen enthalten. Sie hatten einen Spektrometer, der muss allerdings ranfahren an den Stein und dort im Kontakt mit dem Stein bleiben. Sie hatten einen Spektrometer dabei, das hat optisch funktioniert, Minitest. Das konnte also auch bestimmte Minerale nachweisen, einfach durchs Hinschauen.
Minitest, das war sozusagen die Mini-Version?
Genau, die Mini-Version von dem Test. Eine Kamera natürlich war an Bord. Und es war auch wieder eine Version von diesem Mainzer Spektrometer an Bord, das die Elemente nachweisen kann. Wie schon bei Pathfinder. Natürlich viel besser und viel schicker. Aber auch wieder, weil das so gut geklappt hat damals bei Pathfinder, sind die wieder eingeladen worden, sich da zu beteiligen. Das waren so die wichtigsten Instrumente. Man konnte also keine organischen Bestandteile nachweisen und leben schon gleich gar nicht. Sondern man wollte eben Minerale, die mit Wasser zu tun hatten. Wie es sich gezeigt hat, im Gusev-Krater war aber wieder bloß Basalt da, den man ja schon zu genüge kannte. Also große Enttäuschung, Mist, hätten wir doch nicht auf die Geologen gehört, die uns da irgendwas von einem See vorfaseln, ist doch alles bloß vulkanisch. Anders bei dem anderen Rover, der bei der mineralogisch ausgewählten Landestelle niederging, Meridiani Planum war geologisch aus der Umlaufbahn so langweilig wie noch was. Also eine Ebene, völlig flach, bloß ein paar Krater, hätte man als jemand, der an Morphologie interessiert ist, niemals ausgewählt. Hat sich aber gezeigt, das war erst mal das Spannendere. Denn tatsächlich hat man dort gleich, praktisch ganz am Anfang, geschichtete Ablagerungen an Kraterwänden gefunden. Die waren aus dem Orbit mit den damaligen Auflösungen nicht sichtbar. Und in diesen geschichteten Ablagern hat man tatsächlich diese Mineraler gefunden, Hämatit, die auf Wasser hinweisen, und noch andere, die man noch nicht kannte. Omega mit seinen Sulfaten war ja noch nicht da. Aber der Rover hat sehr schnell...
Die man noch nicht von der Erde kannte, oder die man nicht vom Mars kannte?
Die man nicht vom Mars kannte. Auf der Erde, ich glaube, soweit ich weiß, gibt es kein Mineral auf dem Mars, das man nicht von der Erde aus kann. Man hat dort also Sulfate gefunden, wasserhaltige und Hämatit. Das war also total spannend. Man hat alles mehr gefunden, als man sich erträumt hätte, in dieser mineralogisch ausgewählten Landesstelle. Das hat sich dann immer weiter verfestigt. Der Rover ist ja immer noch unterwegs. Ich komm gleich nochmal drauf, welches Ziel er jetzt hat. Und spring nochmal zurück zu dem Gusev Rover. Also die saßen da mit ihren anfangs langweiligen Basaltbrocken und mussten sich jetzt überlegen, wat nu? Und deswegen sind sie dorthin gefahren, wo als nächstes irgendein Objekt aus diesen Basalt-Ebenen rausragt. Das war eine Hügelgruppe, die sogenannten Columbia Hills, ein bisschen im Südosten. Zuerst wusste man nicht, wie lange die Rover überhaupt überleben. Man gibt dann immer bei solchen Missionen sehr konservative erwartete Lebenszeiten an, damit man schnell irgendwas als Erfolg verkaufen kann.
Ja, sechs Wochen war das so.
Ich glaube, 90 Tage oder irgend sowas hätte schon als Erfolg gegolten. Zum Glück haben die noch länger funktioniert, denn nach 90 Tagen wäre er noch nicht bei diesen Columbia Hills gewesen. Und erst dort, als er dann auf diese Hügel raufgefahren hat, die ein Überbleibsel aus einer Vergangenheit in diesem Krater war, die vor diese Basalte zurückweist, hat man dann extrem spannende Sachen auch dort gefunden. Mehrere Hinweise auf wasserhaltige Mineralien, Hinweise auf explosiven Vulkanismus. Es war also so, dass Gusev am Anfang war das noch nicht so, das wahre, aber zum Schluss hat der Spirit Rover extrem interessante Sachen gefunden. Kaum, dass er in diesen Columbia Hills war. Mittlerweile ist er leider tot. Ist, glaube ich, im Jahr 2010 zum Schweigen gekommen.
Hat sich verfahren, hat sich festgefahren.
Hat sich festgefahren und dann war irgendwann der Ofen aus. Ist dann zwangsläufig aus dem Winter nicht mehr aufgewacht. Man konnte ihn nicht richtig hin positionieren, dass die Sonnensegel, die Solarpalele auch im Winter Richtung Sonne schauen. Und das war's dann. Ja, und jetzt nochmal zurück zu dem anderen Rover. Der ist also seit 2004, fährt er nach wie vor in der Gegend rum. Natürlich nicht ziellos, sondern immer zu immer größeren Kratern, wo er immer weiter in die Tiefe schauen kann. Denn je größer der Krater ist, desto tiefer ist auch der Krater, desto weiter kann man an der Kraterwand runterschauen in diesen geschichteten Sedimenten. Irgendwann haben sie dann gesagt, jetzt haben wir aber in Anfangszeiten genug von diesen Sulfaten usw. Wer weiß, wie lange er noch durchhält, aber gehen wir mal auf den größten aller Krater los, die weit und breit in der Gegend sind. Endeavor Krater heißt der, glaube ich ein Durchmesser von über 20 Kilometer. Und dort hatte man aus dem Orbit mit Hilfe von CRISN, das ist schon die Nachfolge, das Nachfolgeinstrument von Omega, hatte man Phyllosilikate festgestellt, Tonminerale.
Also jetzt haben wir auch einen interessanten Aspekt, das finde ich überhaupt gerade so faszinierend. Also nicht nur, dass da gerade viele Missionen sind, dadurch, dass die da alle gerade gleichzeitig aktiv sind.
Sie zeigen sich gegenseitig, wohin man jetzt ist.
Genau, schau doch mal da, da ist was Interessantes. Und dann kann man wieder mit dem Rover irgendwas feststellen, was einen dann vielleicht wieder auf die nächste Spur bringt. Also wir sind ja jetzt hier auch vor allem dieser Endeavour-Creator, ich schau gerade mal nach, der hat im zweiten Halbjahr 2011, also sozusagen gerade mal ein Jahr her, den Bereich überhaupt erst erreicht. Zu dem Zeitpunkt 18 Kilometer schon unterwegs gewesen.
Ja, das ist für Mars ein Rekord natürlich.
Aber die Gesamtsstrecke ist... 31 Kilometer sogar.
Und sie haben die Hoffnung, soweit ich weiß, noch den Lunokod, den die Soviets auf dem Mond rumfahren haben lassen, zu übertrumpfen, der hatte damals 38 Kilometer geschafft. Wer weiß, wie lange jetzt Opportunity noch durchhält, vielleicht können sie die 38 Kilometer toppen.
Aber es ist wirklich, es fasst einem schon fast mit Ehrfrücht, dass das Ding jetzt nach fast neun Jahren immer noch funktioniert, wo man vorher mal dachte, so ein paar Monate schafft er schon.
Also ein paar Monate, wie gesagt, die 90 Tage wären vielleicht etwas kurz gewesen, das ist so definiert worden, um schnell einen Erfolg verkaufen zu können. Aber dass er jetzt wirklich schon seit 2004 rumfahrt, das hätte wahrscheinlich wirklich niemand, auch nur ansatzweise vorherzusagen gewagt. Ja, jetzt ist er an diesem Krater. Er hat aber noch nicht die Phyllosilikate erreicht. Der Kraterrand ist lang, die Phyllosilikate sind an einer bestimmten Stelle. Als die Sonne dort ankam, ist auch wieder Winter geworden. Sie musste also erst mal parken sozusagen, auf einen Hang fahren, der Richtung Äquator geneigt ist, und dann parken, bis der Winter vorbei ist. Und jetzt tastet er sich Richtung der Phyllosilikate vor. Und soweit ich weiß, gibt es auch eine Art informellen Wettstreiter. Bei den Rover-Teams wird jetzt der alte, hautigen Opportunity zuerst an Phyllosilikaten auf dem Mars ankommen, oder wird es der neue Super Duper Rover Curiosity sein? So wie es im Augenblick aussteigt, könnte es Opportunity schaffen, würde ich sagen. Warum sind Phyllosilikate überhaupt so wahnsinnig interessant? Sulfate hatte man schon als Verbitterungsprodukte. Phyllosilikate bilden sich aber unter anderen Umweltbedingungen. Bei den Sulfaten kann man sich vorstellen, dass sie auch unter relativ trockenen Bedingungen in einem sauren Milieu gebildet wurden, also bei niedrigem pH-Wert. Bedingungen, etwas salopp ausgedrückt, die für Leben nicht so das wahre sind. Bei Phyllosilikaten ist es anders. Die bilden sich, erwähnen relativ viel Wasser in Kontakt mit Basaltgerät, und zwar unter mehr oder weniger neutralen pH-Werten. Das wäre für Leben eigentlich eine ganz gute Bedingung. Und deswegen interpretieren viele Forscher die Phyllosilikate auf dem Mars, die auch noch offensichtlich in einer noch weiter zurückliegenden Vergangenheit gebildet worden sind, also noch mehr in der Frühphase vom Mars als die Sulfate. Deswegen bilden die eigentlich das interessanteste Ziel für alle die, die nach Leben suchen wollen oder nach Spuren von Leben. In den Phyllosilikaten könnte es sich auch relativ gut erhalten haben, also Spuren von Leben, Mikrofosilien, die können da ganz gut präserviert werden, auch über lange Zeiten. Und wir reden ja hier über Jahrmilliarden. Und deswegen wäre es schon sehr spannend, die mal aus der Nähe zu beobachten. Aus dem Orbit kennt man sie ja mittlerweile. Aber aus der Nähe hat man sie noch mit keinem Rover bis jetzt untersuchen können.
Was heißt, man weiß, da ist schon was?
Ja, man weiß schon was.
Aber man war halt noch nicht dran.
Und Opportunity ist auch nur noch ein paar Kilometer. Vielleicht sogar mittlerweile schon näher.
Hat man eine Vorstellung davon, welche Mengen da sind, damit die überhaupt dediktiert werden können? Also reicht das, wenn da irgendwie so ein Steinchen rum ist? Oder ist das dann schon so eine große...
Wenn man es aus dem Orbit entdeckt, ist es schon jedenfalls mehr als Opportunity brauchen wird, um schöne Mengen zu machen.
Also er findet es dann auch, wenn er da ist sozusagen.
Ja, sollte er es dann auch finden, wenn er da ist. Wenn er wirklich hinfahren kann. Ist natürlich blöd. Manchmal kann er nicht springen oder kann nicht über eine senkrechte Stufe hinauffahren. Er muss auch noch hinkommen. Das wird man sehen. Der Punkt ist jetzt auch noch, dass Opportunity leider durch die zehn Jahre schon ziemlich gelitten hat. Er fährt noch, er sieht auch noch, aber seine Spektrometer sind nicht mehr ganz fit. Insbesondere der Mössbauer-Spektrometer, der arbeitet mit einer radioaktiven Quelle, bestrahlt damit das Gestein und schaut sich an, was sich dann da tut. Diese radioaktive Quelle ist mittlerweile erschöpft, die hat eine kurze Halbwertszeit und war auch nie für zehn Jahre ausgelegt. Die hatten damit einfach nicht gerechnet. Das heißt, im Augenblick kann er, wenn überhaupt, nur noch sinnvolle Ergebnisse erzielen, wenn er, ich glaube, ein Monat lang da unbeweglich rumsteht und ein Monat lang bestrahlt oder noch länger.
Ich weiß die genaue Zahl nicht mehr. Man könnte sozusagen einfach die Zeit verlängern und dann könnte man nicht mehr.
Der ist schon länger, der schwächelt schon länger. Man muss immer länger strahlen, dass man überhaupt noch was rauskriegt. Das ist bei dem das Problem. Das Minitest funktioniert sowieso schon lange nicht mehr. Wie es mit dem APXS-Spektrometer ausschaut, weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist auch so, dass der an seinem robotischen Arm so eine Art Fräse hatte, um die Gesteine vom Staub zu befreien. Man will ja immer eine möglichst frische Gesteinsoberfläche. Ein Geologe geht immer mit dem Hammer ins Gelände. Und das erste, was er tut, ist, er haut erst mal die Gesteine in zwei, damit man eine frische Bruchfläche hat. So ein Rover kann nicht hemmern, aber er kann wenigstens in Abmaßen abschleifen und dann eine frische Ruhe. Und dieses Schleifgerät ist auch mittlerweile abgeschliffen. Das heißt, er ist zahnlos, wenn man so will. Auch wenn er hinkommt, er wird nicht mehr das machen können, was er mal machen hätte können. Trotzdem wäre es, allein schon Bilder zu sehen, schon ein großer Erfolg. Das wird man sehen müssen. Noch ist es nicht ganz weit in die Saison.
Es kann sein, dass das Opportunity was findet, aber es wäre dann eher ein sportlicher Erfolg.
Es wäre ein Vorgeschmack auf das, was kommen könnte. Und sie könnten den anderen sagen, Edge, wir waren die Ersten.
Na gut, aber jetzt haben wir die Amerikaner nochmal nachgelegt und diesen Lastwagen, öffnen sie das Lastwagen von Labor, da hingebracht. Wird sich rumgesprochen haben, das Mars Space Laboratory, MSL, besser eigentlich bekannt unter dem Namen des Rovers, Curiosity, die Neugear, ein Monstergerät, riesig, so groß wie ein Auto?
Ja, ich hab's letztes Jahr in Nantes bei einer Konferenz gesehen, natürlich nicht, dass das jetzt oben ist, ein baugleiches. Es war sogar noch größer, als ich dachte. Es heißt immer, es ist so groß wie ein Mini Cooper. Also kein sehr großes Auto, aber immerhin ein richtiges Auto. Aber mir scheint es sogar noch breiter zu sein. Also ein riesen Apparat, der dort gelandet ist. Und insofern kann er zwei Sachen noch viel besser, nämlich fahren. Man hofft, dass er viel weiterfahren kann als die Murovers. Und die sind ja schon 40 Kilometer der eine gefahren. Und er hat die noch ausgefeilteren Instrumente an Bord, mit denen man die Zusammensetzung der Oberflächenmaterialien erkunden kann. Das sind die beiden Sachen, die ihn auszeichnen.
Welche Instrumente sind das im Wesentlichen?
Das sind verschiedene Arten von Spektrometern. Einer arbeitet mit Röntgentechnik, einer arbeitet mit Massenspektroskopie. Mit diesen Spektrometern kann man genauer als je zuvor die Elementzusammensetzung, also gibt es in den Gesteinen Eisen, Magnesium und so weiter. Man kann die Mineralzusammensetzung, also gibt es zum Beispiel Hämathit oder Sulfate. Wenn man ein Instrument nennen sollte, das wirklich das absolute Nomen ist, dann ist das das SRM, Sample Analysis on Mars, und die können organische Komponenten feststellen. Das ist also jetzt noch nicht das Gleiche wie Leben feststellen, denn es gibt ja auch organische Moleküle, die nicht von Leben stammen, zum Beispiel von Meteoriten stammen. Aber noch ist bis jetzt auf dem Mars, auch von Viking damals nicht, organisches Material nie nachgewiesen worden. Und jetzt wollen wir es nochmal genau wissen. Gibt es überhaupt organisches Material? Eigentlich sollte man welches finden, weil Meteoriten ständig organisches Material auf dem Mars einprasseln lassen. Dass Viking überhaupt keines gefunden hat, war eine echte Überraschung, weil man hat gedacht, er zumindest leblos, also nicht auf Leben hinweisendes organisches Material müsste es geben. Die Tatsache, dass das nicht gefunden worden ist, weist darauf hin, dass es irgendwas auf der Mars-Oberfläche geben muss, was organisches Material zerstört. Sonst müsste man dieses von Meteoriten stammende organische Materialkalle geben. Man hat mittlerweile einige Substanzen identifiziert, die als Oxidanten gelten könnten, die also organisches Material oxidieren würden und damit zerstören würden. Deswegen versucht man jetzt mit dem SHM ein bisschen in den Untergrund reinzugehen und im Untergrund nachzuschauen, ob es dort organisches Material gibt, das noch nicht oxidiert ist. Das ist, wenn man es in einem Satz zusammenfassen müsste, glaube ich, das große Ziel jetzt. Die Mare Rover, Spirited and Opportunity, die haben nach Wasser gesucht. Der Curiosity Rover sucht nach organischem Material. Er macht natürlich die anderen Sachen auch noch, sucht auch nach Wasser und so weiter. Aber das ist sozusagen der nächste große Schritt vorwärts.
Wir haben es jetzt Oktober 2012. Die Landung ist jetzt noch nicht so lange her, zwei Monate. Man weiß, glaube ich, dass abgesehen von der spektakulären Landung nicht nur alles funktioniert hat, soweit man sich das bisher gedacht hat, sondern auch weitgehend alles funktioniert. Wenn ich das richtig sehe. Irgendwas hat, glaube ich, nicht ganz funktioniert.
So ein Windmesser oder so was. Auch wenn ich den beteiligten Forschern damit natürlich jetzt unrecht tue, aber wegen dem Wind ist man sicher nicht hingeflogen mit diesem Rover. Ja, soweit man weiß, funktioniert alles, was innerhalb des Teams alles nicht funktioniert, wird die Nase jetzt erstmal nicht an die Oberfläche kommen lassen wollen. Was ich gehört habe, das hat jetzt mit der Funktion in dem Sinn nichts zu tun, ist, dass dieses Riesengerät mit seinen extrem komplexen Instrumenten sehr schwer zu handeln ist. Also der Betrieb, bis man überhaupt irgendwo hinfahrt, bis man zur Entscheidung gekommen ist, welches Instrument was macht, wo der Rover arm hingreift. Das scheint extrem komplex zu sein. Und zwar sogar so komplex, dass man langsam an die Grenze desen stößt, was man effizient überhaupt noch machen kann. Also anscheinend, in anderen Worten, ist es extrem langsam, was da alles passiert. Das habe ich jetzt durch Leute gehört, die da ein bisschen in dem Team drin sind. Das ist jetzt auch kein...
Also langsam in der Planung, weil man muss halt so viel...
Ja, langsam in der Planung. Man muss so viel miteinander absprechen. Man muss so viel testen. Man muss so viel Software-Schnittstellen ständig überwachen, dass man da nicht einfach losfahren kann. Das kann man sowieso nie. Aber es dauert wohl erheblich länger und ist erheblich komplexer, als sich die beteiligten Wissenschaftler das gewünscht hätten.
Aber immerhin, unterwegs scheint er ja zu sein. Also es sind hervorragende Bilder geliefert worden, schon von der Landung, was ja schon sehr bemerkenswert war, dass sich das Teil quasi selbst bei der Landung gefilmt hat. Und dann, wie schon erwähnt, vom MRO wurden, glaube ich, auch hochauflösende Bilder von der Landestelle geliefert, wo man also wirklich sehen konnte, wie alles abgeworfen wurde, wo er dann steht etc. Und dann auch schon die ersten Spuren im Sand oder im Stein. Alles schon, ja. Gibt es denn jetzt schon, zunächst einmal vielleicht der Ort, wonach ausgewählt wurde, also der Gale Crater, heißt er glaube ich. Was war da jetzt die Intention, dort hinzufliegen, zu fallen?
Die Minerale, die man da drin gefunden hat. Zuerst mit Omega, dann mit Chrism. Es gab eine groß angelegte Suche nach Landestellen über Jahre hinweg von der NASA, bei der die NASA auch Forscher aus internationalen Gremien und aus überhaupt jedem eingeladen hat mitzumachen. Die machen das aus meiner Sicht bewundernswert transparent, wie sowas ausgesucht wird. Jeder ist eingeladen, seinen Senf dazu beizutragen, zu sagen, wo man gerne landen würde, warum natürlich. Es gab mehrere Workshops, die die Landestellen diskutiert und zunehmend eliminiert haben. Es sind dann zum Schluss vier übrig geblieben. Und die hatten eines gemeinsam. Sie hatten alle interessante Minerale, die man erreichen konnte. Insbesondere Phyllosilicate, die Tonminerale. Die Zeichen eines sehr frühen Mars, in dem viel Wasser unter relativ neutralen pH-Bedingungen war. Zu so einer Stelle wollte man fliegen. Da gab es eben vier, die übrig geblieben sind. Und dann ist der Gelkrater genommen worden. Warum? Weil dort auch Sulfate waren in einer Wechsellagerung. Das war schon mal interessant. Aber es gibt Leute, die sagen, sie haben ihn auch deswegen gewählt. Auch weil da gibt es diesen spektakulären Berg und der macht einfach gute Bilder. Man muss ja auch irgendwas verkaufen an die Öffentlichkeit. Und dieser fünf Kilometer hohe Berg, der wird einfach spektakulärer aussehen als eine Ebene, in der lauter Phylloselikate sind. Viele Forscher, auch unsere französischen Kollegen vom Omega-Team, werden lieber in eine andere Gegend geflogen, wo vielleicht mehr Phylloselikate da sind, vielleicht sogar ältere. Aber die einfach langweiliger ausschaut.
Aber ist es nicht auch so, dass diese Bergformation an der Stelle dann auch solche geologischen Bruchstellen hat, wo man dann eben auch sehr in die Vergangenheit schauen kann?
Nein, das ist im Prinzip eine richtige Sicht der Dinge. Wenn man so einen Berg hat, dann bricht da auch mal was ab. Ein entscheidender Punkt hierbei ist das Alter dieser Ablagerungen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, dass dieser Krater selber nur ungefähr 3,6, 3,7, 3,8 Milliarden Jahre alt ist. Nur. Also aus Erdsicht wäre das extrem alt. Aber es ist nicht die absolute Frühzeit von Mars. Die wäre vor vier Milliarden Jahren und älter. Das heißt also, die Ablagerungen, die in dem Krater sind, sind natürlich jünger als der Krater selbst. Man weiß nicht genau, wie alt, aber auf jeden Fall jünger als diese 3,678. Und das bedeutet, auch wenn man da drin Phyllosilikate findet, Zulfate, werden die nicht in der Frühzeit des Mars gebildet worden, in der absoluten Frühzeit, wo die Chancen auf Leben am höchsten sind. Deswegen haben viele andere gesagt, na lass uns doch nach Marth Wallis gehen, da glauben wir, dass das wirklich die Frühzeit von Mars ist. Ich selber war ein bisschen hin und hergerissen, jetzt nur als Beispiel. Ich denke, die Sichtweise, dass Marth Wallis vielleicht, was die Phyllosilikate und ihre Bedeutung angeht, die bessere Stelle gewesen wäre. Aber, ich sag mal so, Phyllosilikate und Leben ist nicht alles. Der macht ja auch noch andere tolle Sachen. Und aus der Hinsicht kann ich mit Geld gut leben. Der ist spannend. Da gibt es diese Ablagung, die wir woanders schon untersucht hatten im Marth Wallis Marinäris. Es gibt Hinweise auf Flüsse, es gibt ein Delta oder sogar mehrere in dem Krater. Also geologisch ist der sehr spannend.
Tja, jetzt noch die Frage, wie gut er da vorankommt und wie effektiv man das planen kann, um dann auch möglichst viel davon abzugrasen. Aber es sieht so aus, als ob da nochmal so ein Jahrzehnt des Fahrspaßes sich abzeichnet.
Und zumindest von der Energieversorgung des Rovers her wäre das auch kein Problem. Der hat keine Solarpaneele mehr wie die Merrovers. Dem ist also Sommer- und Winterwurscht nichts anzuhaben, wenn man Staub auf ihn herabrieseln lässt. Das war ein Problem bei den Merrovers. Denn wenn man so ein Sonnenpaneele hat, das immer weiter verstaubt, dann wird die Energieausbeute geringer und man muss hoffen, dass durch den Wind wieder freigeblasen wird. Alles kein Problem für MSL. Die haben nämlich Nuklearantrieb über eine Nuklearpathorie. Dadurch wird durch den Zerfall der radioaktiven Elemente Wärme freigesetzt und die wird in Strom umgewandelt. Und diese Nuklearquellen, die sollen wohl mindestens ein Jahrzehnt reichen. Also das ist nicht das Problem bei dem Ding.
Ob man da jetzt was finden wird, das ist jetzt sozusagen noch offen, muss jetzt auch abgewartet werden. Also Dinge passieren, aber es ist jetzt einfach noch zu früh, um jetzt irgendwelche Aussagen darüber treffen zu können, was aus dieser Mission rauskommt, oder?
Ich kann es nicht. Man kann wirklich nur sagen, jetzt warten wir mal noch. Er hat zwar schon schöne Bilder von zum Beispiel diesen Gerölln, die durch Wasser transportiert worden sind, aber spannend wird es, wenn er diese, wenn er diejenigen Sachen untersucht, die eben wirklich auf Leben hinweisen könnte, wenn diese in die Laboratorien zum Einsatz kommen, die organisches Material entdecken können, wenn er die Röntgenstrahlen, Floreszenz einschaltet usw. Also das wird jetzt dann alles kommen. Zeitplan kenne ich nicht, aber ich nehme mal an, vielleicht hören wir im Dezember, wir, ich weiß zwar nicht, aber man hört im Dezember auf der Tagung der American Geophysical Union. Die ist jedes Jahr in San Francisco gegen Jahresende. Das ist die größte geowissenschaftliche Tagung der Welt. Ich glaube, dort werden sie massiv auftreten müssen, um auch wieder zu zeigen, dass die Mission auf dem besten Weg ist. Dort werden wir dann mehr hören.
Vielleicht ist das ja hier auch nochmal was für ein Follow-up einer Raumzeit-Folge, wenn sich dort der Wissensstand um den Mars nochmal etwas weiter verschärft hat. Vielleicht zum Ende nochmal so ein bisschen so ein Blick auf, was man eigentlich jetzt, abgesehen von der Suche nach Leben und generell mehr Erkenntnissen, also was ist sozusagen das, was jetzt eigentlich in Zukunft noch geleistet werden sollte aus Sicht der Wissenschaft? Also was ist noch nicht getan worden? Was müsste man nochmal ausprobieren? Was sind die Aufgaben für kommende Missionen? Was will man jetzt eigentlich noch herausfinden, wo jetzt absehbar ist, dass auch vielleicht LMSL an der Stelle einen noch nicht nennenswert voranbringt? Also jetzt abgesehen von dem bemannten Flug, der jetzt nochmal sehr in der Zukunft steht.
Zwei Dinge brauchen wir. Das erste ist Seismik auf dem Mars. Also wir wollen endlich mal tief in das Mars Innere hineinblicken. Was bewegt sich da? Wie ist er aufgebaut? Wie ist zum Beispiel der Durchmesser des Kerns? Wie dick ist die Kruste? Ganz wichtig. Wie dick ist die Lithosphäre? Wie aktiv ist er noch im Inneren? Also das ist extrem wichtig, ist schon seit Jahrzehnten im Gespräch. Man müsste einfach mal einen Seismometer landen, einen guten, am besten mehrere, ein seismisches Netzwerk aufstellen. Das wäre die Traumvorstellung. Mindestens vier Stationen über den Planeten verteilt, sodass man wirklich den Kern zwischen den Stationen hat und dessen Durchmesser genau feststellen kann. Es ist äußerst bedauerlich, dass so ein Netzwerk immer noch nicht realisiert worden ist. Aber wenigstens hat die NASA vor kurzem entschieden, den ersten Schritt dorthin zu tun, nämlich einen einzelnen Seismometer abzusetzen auf der Mission INSIGHT. Man will also Einsichten in den Mars, in sein Inneres gewinnen. Das finde ich absolut richtig, diesen Schritt jetzt zu tun. Und zwar möglichst schnell. Die Mission soll 2016 starten, einen Seismometer an Bord haben und im Institut für Planetenforschung werden wir auch ein Gerät entwickeln, das den Wärmefluss auf dem Mars in der Lithosphäre messen kann. Und da kann man auch Aussagen über den thermalen Zustand des Planeten und über seine thermale Entwicklung herleiten.
Das ist so ein langes Band, was man in den Boden hineinbringt?
Bei einem Band hätte man Schwierigkeiten, es hineinzubringen. Nein, man muss dem Band schon den Weg schaffen über eine Art Permitratorsonde. Man muss also eine gewisse Zeit lang einen gewissen Weg in das Innere zurücklegen und dann an mehreren Punkten entlang dieses Wegste Temperatur hochgenau messen, um einen Temperaturgradienten zu ermitteln. Und aus dem kann man dann den Wärmefluss ableiten.
Aber das ist quasi ein Länder, der dann eben auch stehen bleibt?
Ja, der bleibt stehen. Ein Seismometer muss ja nur rumstehen.
Genau, und der bohrt sich dann sozusagen in den Boden rein.
Der Seismometer bleibt oben, aber diese Wärmeflussonde, die muss etwas in das Innere rein. Den Seismometer muss man nur möglichst gut verankern, dass er nicht von Wind zum Beispiel...
Wie tief will man da in den Boden hineinbohren?
Ich glaube, bis zu ein paar Metern gehen die optimistischen Annahmen. Ich bin immer sehr skeptisch, ob die Sonde, das ist kein richtiger Bohrer, das ist so eine Art Hammer-Sonde, ob die wirklich so weit reinkommt, das wird man sehen müssen. Das wäre also der erste Schritt, der gemacht werden sollte.
Dann gäbe es zumindest überhaupt schon mal eine Messung.
Dann weiß man zumindest von einem Seismometer schon, mit einem Seismometer kann man auch schon einiges machen. Ich glaube, den Kerndurchmesser kann man nicht so gut rauskriegen, aber die Kustendicke zum Beispiel, ein ganz wichtiger Parameter, den kann man damit rauskriegen. Die Kustendicke ist ein wichtiger Indikator, wie weit sich dieser Planet differenziert hat. Denn in der Kruste ist ja anderes Material als im Mantel. Und der zweite Schritt, noch wichtiger, aber leider noch in etwas weiterer Zukunft, wäre eine Probe vom Mars zurückzuholen. Eine oder mehrere Proben, die man dann auf der Erde, nach allen Regeln der Kunst, in den Laboratorien untersuchen kann. Davon wird schon seit sehr, sehr langer Zeit geredet. Aber leider scheint der Zeitpunkt einer tatsächlichen Sample-Return-Mission immer gleich weit in der Zukunft zu liegen oder sogar sich noch zu verstärken. Es hieß mal, das Ganze könnte innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre der Fall sein, dann 15. Im Augenblick ist, glaube ich, die optimistischste Annahme nach wie vor so 15 Jahre in der Zukunft. Es kommt nicht näher, es wird nicht wirklich...
Das ist ja auch eine ziemlich aufwändige Geschichte, weil man muss ja dann wieder auch mit irgendwas zurückfliegen. Das heißt, man muss in irgendeiner Form von der Mars-Oberfläche wieder wegkommen, was ja nun so einfach nicht ist, ist ja so ähnlich wie die Erde, wenn auch kleiner, aber trotzdem die Gravitation ist nicht zu vernachlässigen.
Wir müssen hinkommen, wir müssen wieder zurückkommen, wir müssen hinreichend Material zurücknehmen. Also mit einem Mikrogramm wäre man nicht zufrieden. Und wir müssen das Zeug ja dort auch aufsammeln. Und zwar möglichst nicht nur eine Probe, sondern verschiedene. Deswegen schaut das zumindest bis vor kurzem gültiges Szenarium so aus, dass eine Mission schon mal hinfliegt und dort mit einem Rover verschiedene Gesteine aufsammelt. Dann kommt die nächste, fliegt zu diesem Rover, landet dort, nimmt das Gestein, das der Rover schon von verschiedenen Stellen aufgesammelt hat. Die Sonne muss also nicht selber noch rumfahren. Fliegt dann damit vom Mars weg, überwindet die Mars-Anziehungskraft, parkt in einer Umlaufbahn um den Mars und eine dritte holt es dann dort ab. Das ist nicht ganz einfach, vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Klingt auch nicht so. Wird auch nicht umsonst zu haben sein. Es löst aber zumindest das Problem, dass eine einzelne Mission nicht alles erledigen können wird. Aber dieses Szenario hat sich auch schon wieder zerschlagen, das sollte nämlich mit einem gemeinsamen ESA-NASA-Rover losgehen, der Gesteine einsammelt und sie dann in einem Art Container erst mal aufbewahrt. Da gibt es auch Probleme. Kann man Proben überhaupt aufbewahren? Über Jahre hinweg, ohne dass sie durch die kosmische Strahlung beschädigt werden. Denn was man eigentlich da drinnen haben will, sind Spuren von Leben und die sind am sensibelsten, was Strahlung anbelangt. Also da gibt es viele ungelöste Probleme. Nachdem sich der gemeinsame ESA-NASA-Rover aber zerschlagen hat, als die NASA aus dem gemeinsamen Projekt ausgestiegen ist, weil es im Augenblick keiner, auch was mit ExoMars wird, ist im Augenblick offen. Das wird wahrscheinlich erst im November.
Also ExoMars ist der eigentliche Name für diesen Rover.
ExoMars ist der eigentliche Name für dieses Projekt, für diesen Rover. Was da draus wird, ist im Augenblick offen. Die ESA wird im November auf ihrem großen Treffen beschließen, wie es da weitergeht. Aber vielleicht wird sie auch da noch keine endgültige Entscheidung treffen, sondern nur erst mal so ein bisschen weitermachen, damit man es nicht für tot erklären muss. Ich weiß es im Augenblick nicht, was da draus wird.
Ja, das bringt uns hier ans Ende des Überblicks. Das war ein ganz spannender Einblick hier in viele Missionen. Auf jeden Fall reißt das Interesse am Mars nicht ab. Es geht immer weiter. Weitere Missionen starten und ich denke, es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob wirklich jeder 2-Jahres-Slot, der sich immer wieder anbietet, um dort hinzufliegen, auch irgendwie genutzt werden würde.
Das steht jetzt zurzeit gerade in Frage. Bis jetzt war es soweit. Der nächste wird auch nochmal genutzt werden durch die Maven-Mission, ein Orbiter der NASA, der insbesondere die obere Atmosphäre untersuchen soll, wie viel Material geht da immer in den Weltraum verloren. Wichtige Sache, vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz so spektakulär wie ein Rover, der herumfährt, aber auf jeden Fall ein schönes Missionskonzept. Aber danach tut sich jetzt inzwischen eine Lücke auf. Und da, glaube ich, kann Ihnen keiner im Augenblick mit Sicherheit sagen, ob und wenn ja, mit welcher Mission die und die nächsten Lücken geschlossen werden wird.
Ja, ganz vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zum Mars. Ich denke, da machen wir jetzt erstmal den Deckel zu. Da gibt es noch viel zu erzählen. Ich sehe auch, Mars hat noch hier Potenzial, Raumzeit noch weitere Inhalte zu spenden.
Ja, gerne, hat mich gefreut. Und ich bin auch sicher, dass die Sonden, die derzeit noch aktiv sind, und vielleicht kommt ja noch die eine oder andere zu, genügend Material für die Zukunft liefern werden.
Okay, dann war's das. Vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.